foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
it's us man hey hey
welcome my friends and my foes to fat
man beyond I'm Kevin Smith I am Mark
Bernardin
hey oh uh we're back kids to [__]
talk
all the culture that pops
um and uh of course talk about
Indiana Jones
and the dial of Destiny
as well as uh what other things that
were
into and and interested in I'm sorry I'm
tired as [__] I just got back from the
East Coast early this morning I was on
like a six o'clock flight so I was up at
4 15 to head up to Newark Airport
um we were in uh
well last week I went and saw my mom in
Florida the hospital and stuff so I
stayed with her for a few days and um
then I went to Jersey
and did a bunch of stuff at the secret
stash Jay and some Bob Seger's test
because as you know Mark
I own a comic book store
see all that's left for you to own in
your quest for like nerd Monopoly is an
arcade
it's like I got a comic store you just
gave me something to shoot for I got a
movie theater I was talking to Jennifer
I was like it's tomorrow's Fourth of
July what do we do and she's like we can
go to the movies and I was like I own a
movie theater
I've I've you know it's gonna sound like
[__] rich man's problems but I bought
all my hobbies and now there's nothing
I'm like Alexander man I've reached the
end of the new world there was nothing
left to conquer him I went
um but we were back East at Jay and
Silent Bob's secret stash we had a
signing my two
Dark Horse secret stash press hard
covers listen to this [__]
[__]
to the quality
it's made of this is [__] hard as
[__]
[Music]
Dark Horse makes a nice [__] book so
quick stops was one of the comic books I
did
um with a bunch of different artists
masquerade is the book I do with Danny
mcelfresh and with uh Captain rip man
John sprengelmeyer and uh they've
basically what Darkhorse likes to do is
you do four issues of a book and then
they put it into
yeah
hard cover and they put all you know the
covers in it and [__] it's like [__]
quality man
um so masquerade volume two
just came out I think last week so issue
five of that ongoing story is now a
comic book store the first four issues
are now in hardcover so this go this
ghost comic book stores but it also goes
to [__] bookstores that's where
they're clever right they'll put it
bookstores because those still exist
apparently and then quick stops issues
one through four they put in this Nifty
hardcover this great John Spangled Meyer
cover after Michael allred's artwork
from Chasing Amy and then my next run of
quick stops begins in December once
masquerade comes to a close then quick
stops we'll begin again so I was at the
secret stash red designing we used to do
a thing when we had signings at the
secret stash where we're like hey man
starts at noon and people would just
line the [__] up and there was like a
thousand people and then you like you
were there until three four in the
morning now we just do it through like
the reservation system so it's like
clear this is lot so you know when to
get there you're never going to be
standing thank God because it was so
[__] hot people would have been
already sweating balls
so I did two days of signings at the
secret stash Brian O'Hara was with me on
on the first day as was David Van Dyke
who did one of the covers of quick stops
he did the cover
that's uh all the Dante's let me find it
um
it done in The Breakfast Club Style
right there nice for Brian O'Hara and he
played many Hicks characters and all the
vsq movies
um and Brian Holland was there
that was on Saturday then Saturday night
we had a screening at
um smog Castle Cinemas my movie theater
I don't know if you know this Mark but I
also own a mobile theater
um so that was sold out and wonderful
and Brian o'holland and Jeff Anderson
came back for that we did the clerk's
cartoon marathon it's called Bears
driving the clerk's cartoon Marathon and
you know the clerks cartoon
we made six ABC air two and then
canceled it and then they put it out on
a DVD
um years ago called like Clerk's cartoon
uncensored or something like that
but
I've never watched it with a bunch of
people
and so we had 230 people packed in
watching it that show was [__] funny
man honestly pound for pound minute for
minute the funniest thing I've ever been
involved with
um I I of the stuff I've made
um my movies aren't nearly as funny as
the clerk's cartoon because the Clark's
cartoon was like not just me I generally
it's always just me making writing my
flicks drugs my flicks but the clerk's
cartoon there was me and Dave Mandel
Scott Moser Brian Kelly who went on to
write for for The Simpsons Steve lookner
Paul deaney wrote an episode so like the
joke per minute ratio is really [__]
high so it was playing like through the
roof it was awesome we do auctions
before like the screenings that I do
it's mod castle where we auction off
stuff Marx had to sit through that when
we did that one Beyond there
um Batman Beyond which is coming Tuesday
August 25th but if you didn't get
tickets
you hear that echo in my empty room
because that's all sold out man that
[__] sold the [__] out but if you want
to get tickets for uh the day after is
August 26th me and Mark are doing uh
keep calm and Curry on the Tim Curry
double feature where you can watch
clue and then you watch Legend with a q
a between them through for the price of
[__] one that was Mark's idea
um so we did an auction it was the
highest grossing auction we ever did
um like basically nothing ever starts on
time at smog Castle so the show was a
seven o'clock show we started at 7 30.
we didn't start
Clerk's cartoon Marathon until about
nine nine
so between we do two episodes then we
just do a q a then do two episodes then
q a so the first two episodes followed
by q a with Brian and Jeff second two
episodes are followed by a q a with me
and then the third set of two episodes
was all of us uh together q a after the
Q a we did pictures VIP pictures and
stuff
um where people pay like a little more
we take pictures with us and then after
that we had a secret screening
yeah I can't say what it was but it it
went on forever
wait no what I mean uh but that [__]
started at 2 30 in the morning
I would say easily 50 to 60 people
[__] stuck around to watch it when it
was over because it's a long cut right
um they [__] stumbled out into broad
daylight it was already [__] becoming
the day in Atlantic Highlands New Jersey
so I'm telling you man if you're if
you're not if you're sleeping on
smodcast Castle events
you're you can sleep at smodcast a
little bit they [__] go all night
long come to spawn Castle but uh the
next few things that I'm doing are sold
out so like the Superman live script
reading is sold out fat man beyond is
currently sold out
um but we'll be adding some more stuff
to the schedule because I had back there
um mid-august
um it looks like if sag doesn't strike
fingers crossed
we'll be making our look our low budget
low low budget movie 4 30 movie even if
sag strikes I think like 3 million and
under movies are exempt or whatever
um so yeah we're going back to work
um I know I'm a writer and I'm striking
but
I'm also a director and the director
told the writer [__] off and he's going
back you don't get to come to set
exactly so so while we're there we'll be
doing lots of stuff I got Justin Long
cornered to come do because he's going
to be in 4 30 movie as well so I was
like would you want to come and do a
screening of Tusk he was like [__]
absolutely
so I know that's in the offing we're
gonna do a a double feature called
Hollywood with Harley so there's yoga
hosers followed by once once upon a time
in Hollywood
sorry movies then I want everyone loved
and one nobody [__] ever heard of her
so
um but more coming there so that was our
Saturday night into Sunday morning and
then Sunday I had another mini signing
at the stash only like two hours for two
groups and then Sunday night we showed
Blues Brothers which on Saturday night
we had sold like 50 tickets for and then
overnight took a huge [__] jump so we
had 130 people to come see the Blues
Brothers and that [__] movie plays
like a dream that was a 42 year old
movie and it's still [__] works man
like it wasn't polite laughter granted
it's Marcus we make it raucous so it's
like people are screaming and hollering
and cheering throughout every movie and
stuff but
it was delightful that was one of my
favorite movies as a kid and it [__]
held up man in the screening that we had
so uh we got finished I guess it like
midnight or one in the morning or
something and then I packed and I slept
for like half an hour I got up and got
on the plane so I'm long story short I'm
a little sleepy how are you so I also
left out on Friday night we watched Indy
we did a watch with Kev Indiana Jones
and the dial of Destiny so I saw the
movie we're going to be talking about
and stayed awake through the whole
[__] thing like a big boy
we'll have a review for you in a little
bit that's all me what about you what
you been up to uh this past week was uh
well what is today today's Monday so
last week
um was a bit of picketing was a bit of
being out there on the lines
um what's going on uh what's going on
out there on the lines
um
same as it ever was you know I mean the
the big news is that we have effectively
shut down all production in Los Angeles
all right yeah which is uh which is a a
big move so stay away from Atlantic
Highlands New Jersey please well now we
know yeah
uh so like you know and the spirits are
still really high
um they've adjusted the hours of
picketing being mindful of the fact that
it's going to be hottest balls in in the
San Fernando Valley it already is it was
100 degrees out there today
and so standing on the picket line for
four hours a day is going to be a bit
much when it's desert hot out there
particularly in the valley Jesus yeah so
they've adjusted that a little bit
um I had a comic book come out last week
um I wrote a a it's an anthology book
and I wrote a story in Star Wars Darth
Vader black white and red I came out
finally that came out finally so look at
that [__] look at that you [__] did a
Star Wars story before what label but
that's Marvel
you worked a for Marvel and B for Star
Wars I did my first ever star war okay
you took a war to the Stars what was the
lag were there any parameters were they
like you can't do that
um it was odd the things that they did
have parameters about
um it was all like you know Darth Vader
isn't that powerful Darth Vader can't
quite do that Darth Vader's use of the
force Manifest this way not that way
this person would be a commander not a
lieutenant commander because we don't
have Pips for the tenant Commander like
some of them were just sort of small
in-world Canon things some of them were
like larger like you know he wouldn't
have a he wouldn't have the the
well I don't even know what you call it
like the meditation Suite that he had on
the executor yeah you see him in in
Empire and that you know you see with
his helmet off and the giant chamber
whatever
[__] the jerk off tube
the spooge cylinder
um [__] pull it and [__]
um he's like he wouldn't have that on
his own private shuttle that's only on
the executor so you have to like stuff
like that but by and large like
lucasfilm was really easy to work with
they they did not [__] with the the core
parts of the story that I was interested
in telling they just made it better so
thanks lucasfilm [__] hey man a
Marvel book too no less Marvel book it's
been it's been a minute since I've
worked for Marvel but
um did you say it was black and white
it's black white and red
um so there's only three colors and the
red naturally for the lightsaber but
it's a cheap [__] book to print right
there they must be making money hand
over fish
we got two colors yo
yeah
um but yeah so it was fun so I you know
banged around La from when I spotted in
the store I would sign it
um so they had a couple shops in the
valley and you know maybe I'll do some
more maybe when I'm back East I'll we'll
talk to the stash folks and I know for a
fact uh I saw Mike zapsick while I was
there of course for the signing and he
had ordered he had a he showed me a
stack of adoras and then a stack of the
Star Wars thing and something else what
did you also write that
he showed me that because he was like
when Mark comes back in August we're
gonna have a signing and I was like are
you asking me or telling me
he's planning on it you're [__]
spoken for when you come back yeah and
there's a I have a Muhammad Ali graphic
novel that's coming out in mid August
um which will also be perfect to sign at
the stash for a bit
um and we'll have a we'll have a launch
event here in La that I can talk about a
little bit later but it's going to be
super cool I'm very excited about it
look at look at [__] look at us we're
not just [__] walking a walk [__]
we're talking to talk or whatever the
[__] we work in comics there's a lot of
people that hover in comics adjacent
[__] businesses and [__] like that
where they suck off of comics like
[__] ticks but we [__] put in the
time we're in the trenches look at this
[__] remember
Heavy hardcover books Mark's making
comics in three [__] colors God damn
it we're doing the work
this is the [__] we dreamed about when
we were children the idea of [__]
being able to write comics and now as
adults we do that thing sure there are
other better filmmakers who tell their
comic book stories on the big screen
but
but all in color for a dime that's what
I say
or 4.99 yeah
very expensive I asked somebody at the
Statue I was like how much is a
masquerade and they're like four bucks I
was like for a comic book look at my
part of this establishment
did we really only put 20 pages in there
yeah
they made it way more
it's becoming like records real rare fun
it used to be a thing of a disposable
medium for children with pocket change
now
all adults you gotta have money you
gotta have a [__] 401k to read Comics
these days you gonna have a real last
job
what yeah [__] yeah
um
when is this strike going to end going
back to the Writers Guild strike why
can't you end it ah stop it yeah just
stop I can I can just have them bring me
the standard rich and famous contract
and we can just just ink that [__] up
and go back to work they said like in
the beginning this is probably gonna go
on to the fall and I remember being like
no but it looks like it will go on it
could it depends you know still much
depends on what the actors decide to do
um the actors contract uh expired uh
last Friday
um they've now extended it until the
12th so they can continue to sort of
negotiate and we'll see what happens
either they will go on strike
um which is I think still unlikely but
possible
um there were some big letters and
petition that was going around that was
being signed by actors
um up and down the alphabet tree from
A-list to z-list well Street signed it
signed it you know it's like let's go on
strike damn it Jay Law signed it she's
an actor she is indeed
um so people are [__] signed it he
was just like nobody's gonna meet
anything anymore unless you [__] make
a deal you ain't gonna meet Fockers
parents nothing
all the meetings are canceled said Ben
Stiller yes you can meet these nuts
eat these [__] nuts the camera sorry
um so we'll see what happens if they go
on strike then that puts enormous
pressure on the on the motion picture
Alliance to come back to the table if
the actors get a deal that they're happy
with
um it only helps us as the writers
because it's a sort of bottom-up
negotiation the DGA said one floor I'm
assuming the actors will send another
floor which will then give us room to
build off of it for the Riders
um
it still feels as if we're looking at
Labor Day ish maybe a little bit later
maybe a little bit earlier
um I don't know I would like it to
happen this [__] summer at the box
office and I say this as not just a
movie fan but as a [__] exhibitor
like
they better get some writers and get
back to [__] work like yeah nothing
seems to be working at the box office
man last time we gathered together to
ask the Lord's blessing we were talking
about the Flash
nobody's talking about the flash anymore
it's gone it left smodcast Castle
Cinemas wow it was only there for less
than two weeks I asked Ernie I was like
where's the flash he's like it flushed
what because yeah man [__] nobody was
coming and [__] and I was like God damn
it
um they're struggling at the box office
this this year there's three movies that
the entire industry pinning all their
hopes to right now
Mission Impossible
Oppenheimer
and Barbie
they're like they only these three
movies can save the summer box office
because right now it's off by some
ridiculous percentage amount from last
year even you know coming back from
covet has been
a struggle
um but you know I I used to you know me
I'm like [__] I like everything and I'm
like I can't make that movie so of
course I appreciate it and [__] Mark's
the other guy who's like [__] them all
and let God's order that
now as an exhibitor I got skin in the
game where I'm like can you make a
[__] movie that sticks around long
enough for for us to saw some [__]
popcorn
like God damn it like I'm doing better
at my movie theater with old ass movies
man
the night that we had 130 people for
Blues Brothers we had 39 people for
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny
yeah
I mean I think that like the thing that
the pandemic did was it broke people of
the habit of just going to the movies
you know because it used to be you know
before anybody gave a [__] about
gathering in public you know if you were
a movie go are you a moviegoer like and
I'll go I'll find something to go see
you know good bad or indifferent I'll go
see it because I just like going to the
movies
whereas now it seems to be like no It's
gotta be I have to have a reason to go
to the movies like you gotta either sell
it to me hard and well you got to
promise me quality I have to know
there's quality because like across the
spider verse has done exceptionally well
like that will open to like 110 million
dollars domestic you know and is doing
pretty well overseas whereas Indiana
Jones open to 60. flash open to 50
something like
you know even even fast fast X which had
previously been bulletproof in the
domestic box I was open to like 80 which
was very soft for that movie
a lot a lot of folks in chat are like uh
Hey man the movies are bad that's why
people nobody's going it's not that kids
there have always been bad movies take
it from a guy who's made a bunch like
bad movies will be with us forever like
cancer like that's not it it's not like
movies suddenly got bad
it it's different it's there an audience
has been trained now to like wait like
well why would I [__] go number one
movies are too expensive like I'll be
honest as an exhibitor I'm going to say
that because I've been to other movie
theaters and [__] I see their prices
now you come to smodcast and Cinemas you
paying ten dollars to see a movie prime
time
unless you're coming to see one of our
events then we up charging [__] but a
brand new movie 10 bucks and [__] and
our popcorn's reasonable so our drinks a
lot of places man they're like really
[__] charging Crazy Prices because
they got them the comfortable seats
that's something we don't have it's my
castle Cinemas we don't believe in
Comfort we believe in discount
um you're not paying for no comfy seat
you're paying to see a goddamn movie and
make that seat uncomfortable so when the
movie's over you want to get the [__]
out but I think the price of movies is
high and I also think that the audience
the shrinking theatrical window
definitely [__] hurt and as much as
people like if I wait a few weeks I'll
be able to watch in the comfort of my
own home home viewing has become
preferable why would you want to go out
when you can watch something in your own
home on a nice giant TV with a [__]
picture quality is pristine and [__] I
mean look flash came out June 16th flash
is hitting streaming July July 18th in
[__] 17 days what's the second third
third in [__] 15 to in two weeks
you're gonna be able to watch The Flash
at home a movie that was just in the
movie theaters and now
you know that's probably not the case to
point to they they had a tough run at
the box office pun intended but that's
you've got an audience it's like why
would I [__] bother going out and yes
it would help if like the movies were
stronger but it's not just bad movies
and I suppose some people is like it's
[__] all the movies are too woke
that's not it either man like it has
nothing to do with bad movies and bulk
movies it has everything to do with how
people have been retrained to to ingest
films after during covet and after covet
um and also it's like in some cases
you know think about when we were kids
yeah TV had movies and that was it I'm
in the outdoors but [__] that so
nowadays it's like you could [__]
hang out on Tick Tock for two hours be
more vastly entertained than by sitting
through [__] some movies
um you know they're just other choice
video games we're not a factor when we
were kids now he got you know we had
Pitfall but [__] who would rather
like fall over going to see Indiana
Jones nowadays you know you got these
Incredible video games take you hours to
play and [__] then they make TV shows of
them and [__] like it's not bad movies
bad movies been around forever you know
that's that's the part of the the gamble
of going to see any movies you see a
trailer and you're like oh my God this
looks amazing I'm [__] here's my two
bits and you get in the theater and you
[__] you're like [__] tricked again
God damn it but Living Hope die in
despair but yeah it's it's Bleak out
there for uh it's it's hard out there
for a film exhibitor lyrics of that song
Went years and years ago and again this
ain't just an opinion of a dude who's
like I watch movies and so I get to say
what I want I'm talking about this guy
who like my business depends on [__]
people coming to the movie theater so
that they could buy [__] popcorn and
soda and [__] like that and
it's it's been a tough [__] summer
man me and Ernie smodcast will keep
Ernie O'Donnell
sat down to go over like the rest of the
summer and the fall schedule looking for
like where's the [__] where's the Big
Hope where's the [__] movie where's
where's the top gun Maverick that's
going to keep people coming back and
coming back coming back and right now
it's across the spider verse uh Ernie
had let across the spider verse go but I
think we're probably gonna grab it again
because
it's still a draw for heaven's sakes I
mean hell they get a double feature you
into the spider-verse and across the
spider verse are we allowed to do that
yeah probably yeah yeah why don't you
[__] be the smartcast
that's a good ass idea
um yeah man it's it's kind of crazy
um
it's somebody said are you serious films
under 3 million are exempt
to film uh well sag has said that
they're not
gonna be going after low budget movies
because a low a low budget or no budget
movie
if it's like we're not making that movie
[__] the amp TP doesn't give a flying
[__] the amtp
what is it called amptp thank you we're
in the business of making huge movies
and [__] television shows or networks
are in the business making television
shows
um that make or break this business
[__] you know
you think
Clerks the threat of not making clerks
would have stopped a single made a
single Studio pause and like you know
going like we better settle this [__]
strike so the way I understand it is Sag
is like hey man if you've got a low
budget flick
it ain't like you're not Jennifer
Lawrence you know we're [__] signing
a letter might mean something to a
studio guy what are your thoughts on
that
um you know I do I do think that the
whole point of at the very least the WJ
action
is to is to cut off the pipeline right
is to make make the financial pain real
and so the wga is like yeah I mean
there's there's certain things we can't
stop you from doing if you're if you
like I can make a short film I think
because I don't have a distributor I
don't have a studio behind it like I'm
putting my own money into it or
Kickstart or whatever that is but I
don't have a place for it to be you're
just making art and we're not going to
stop you from making art
um sag might have a similar uh viewpoint
on it which is the threshold is
different where it's like for three
million dollars
or less
you know like that is not you know it
and if you have a distributor or Studio
they might you know even if they're on
strike if they're not on strike then
they don't care
um but if they're on strike and they
have waivers for indie films like yeah
do what's do what's permitted do what's
what's quote unquote legal in the eyes
of the guilds that you belong to but you
know Don't Stray
but play Within the lines
uh electric Eliminator five and Chad
said 18 for a matinee where
I get like there's no way man you come
to smodcast with Cinemas kids
ten dollars you pay on Tuesdays eight
dollars if you're military you pay Seven
dollars
if you're an old [__] like me and Mark
there's also a senior discount I think
it's like eight bucks or something prime
time
go see Sweeney Todd which I did it was
awesome
when does dune two come out that's a lot
of that's another movie that people like
that'll save us I was like yeah because
Dune saved us last time yeah I mean
November November 2nd I think that's a
ways off man that's a ways off you know
and like that first dude move was the
day and date thing they released on HBO
Max the then HBO Max
and also in theaters
and like it did pretty well in theaters
but nobody really knows I think Doom 2
will be the litmus test of what the
audience does the audience really care
that much about Dune if they have to go
see it in the theaters and pay for it I
mean I do them they're opening night but
because
a long live the fighters but B
[__] Christopher Walken in a dune
movie yeah I saw that I saw him in the
trailer the spies must flow you know I'm
so glad you went for the impression I
had to I thought for a second I was
going to try it I was like I'm not Ralph
Garmin but apparently you thought you
were Ralph Carmen and went for it yeah
what's what was he playing in that movie
he's playing the emperor shaddam IV oh
is he he's uh Jose Ferrer yeah
the faith wishes to meet you he can with
my blade Seth Martin and Chad says
Quentin's movie theater is eight dollars
for two movies
yeah I mean rep houses that's the the
bread and butter which I you know look I
appreciate that but we were talking
about new movies kids but to be honest
with you [__] go see old movies man
especially if you see two for eight
bucks but most of these other people are
quoting prices of what it costs to go
see
uh a new movie uh Max Ramos says uh
whenever my dad and I go out every
Saturday it's 27 to 35 dollars for
tickets
uh Dave mundane said 21 per ticket plus
12 parking at Cinemark Playa Vista Playa
Vista
oh it's Banff man everybody what's up
man wrong hold on
look at that [__] weird
rubbery CG there we go
I uh I injured my hand uh last week and
so I can't I did not travel with my
family so I've been at home I've been
going and seeing movies like every other
day I went yeah I finally saw Guardians
3 it was at 10 A.M showing it was 13 for
the ticket and 24 for popcorn and a
drink
so I spent 37
37 to see a matinee of Guardians of the
Galaxy by myself
which is crazy sounds so [__] high
you could have
gotten a ticket
to New Jersey
and you're standing there being like JC
10 bucks sorry no they're like I'm sorry
JC it's ten dollars also we don't have
Guardians anymore
I mean I'm pretty sure tickets were like
25 each for the Chinese in IMAX maybe
even 30.
are you [__] yeah I saw the flash
it was 30 bucks for my my Imax ticket
for the flash opening weekend
wait this town they they really built
the customer here out here in Los
Angeles don't they
yes they do
uh this guy here uh Charles says my
local AMC isn't terrible eight dollars
during the day 11 prime time that's not
bad that's only a buck more than us more
than two movies a month A-list is worth
it yeah they got a lot of those things
you could join up for where you could
pay one price and you can go see as many
movies as you want wow I'm now looking
just idly at uh the Indiana Jones and
the Dallas Destiny if I wanted to go see
it at 9 55
in uh in the Chinese Theater in IMAX
so far they've sold
conservatively speaking 30 tickets
and that house must hold 500 people
900 I think is how many yeah Chinese has
and uh it's 25 a ticket 24.75 for an
adult
I mean that's
flabbergasting look like if you want to
go see like I did the clerk's
convenience store and [__] and you know
it wasn't cheap I think the tickets were
like 50 to 75 bucks but I was there and
I did a whole [__] show afterwards
you know what I'm saying like you get
value [__] when you buy a ticket to a
Smart Castle show that I'm throwing it
ain't no two hour Affair it's like a
five to seven hour [__] show so
you're getting time and quality for your
women not quality quantity more than
anything else for your [__] dollar
but like 25 bucks to go see a [__]
movie yeah
no wonder everyone's staying home
you know like if it used to be like it's
gonna cost you a hundred dollars to go
out like a movie dinner babysitter
parking all of that stuff you're looking
more like 150 200 dollars
if you're a you know a
couple of people with children wanting
to go to dinner in the movie
that's a lot of [__] money
um oh boy oh boy yeah I don't know
anyway you know what we gotta do an ad
speaking of [__] money we gotta pay
some goddamn building uh kids this year
episode of fat man beyond has two
sponsors tonight uh but the first
sponsor
uh I would like to say that they don't
make it hard to be a sponsor but their
whole business is about making it hard
good nice thank you uh we'd like to
thank the good Folks at BlueTube
Bluetooth kids are they're our sponsors
tonight how well does Bluetooth work you
get a month for free all caps so you
might as well try it man you're gonna
like it and so will your partner
see those eyebrows I did they're nice
it's all about the nookie what the
nookie blue chew kids this episode is
sponsored by bluetooth Let's Talk About
Sex guys remember the days when you were
always ready to go
yeah yeah it was this morning ready to
go now as soon as we're done with the
show I'm gonna go [__] bury it deep
um in my hand now you can increase your
performance and get that extra
confidence in bed listen up I got three
words for your two words and then an
internet word bluetooth.com
because dot com's really not a word man
Bluetooth is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as Viagra Cialis and Levitra
but in chewable tablets at a fraction to
cost [__] swallowing you know what I'm
saying well I'm swallowing until later
yeah later on that's later on but uh you
just chewing it you're chewing this [__]
for a fraction of a cost of the cost
kids way cheaper than seeing a movie in
IMAX in Los Angeles apparently you could
take them anytime day or night so you
could plan ahead or be ready whenever an
opportunity arises man process is simple
sign up at bluetube.com consult with one
of their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved God damn it you're
going to receive your prescription
within days the best part it's all done
online
that's it so no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations and no
waiting in line at the [__] pharmacy
who's got time for that [__]
[__] the pharmacy bluetooth.com that's
their new model
Bluetooth tablets they're made in the
goddamn USA
[__] blue
repaired and shipped direct to your door
in a discreet package because you don't
want your neighbors to know how hard you
[__]
take it away mark
uh they always say first impressions are
important what about Lasting Impressions
and Bluetooth wants you to help you have
better sex so discover your options at
bluejew.com tune it and chewing it and
chewing it well
and we got a special deal for our
listeners try Bluetooth free when you
use our promo code Fatman at checkout
just make five dollars in shipping
that's bluetooth.com promo code Fatman
to receive your first month for free
visit bluetooth.com for more details on
important safety information and we
thank the good folks of Bluetooth for
sponsoring this episode we do man we
thank the good folks of blue chew with
all of our hard ass heart hard because
we eat the blue chew we chew it we don't
swallow it like
only a dick would swallow a [__] pill
or make them hard chew it God damn it
how welcome glitch you work you're gonna
get a month for free so you might as
well try it see what I'm saying follow
that logic you're gonna like it and so
will your partner uh we thank the good
Folks at Blue chew for sponsoring us man
they're still they're still [__] they
still believe in US
I mean
I lost the critics in my career but
Bluetooth still Believes In Me
um
what should we talk about first
I don't know should we do late night
with the devil yeah let's talk about
um yeah I want to talk about that me and
Mark saw a [__] amazing movie uh
thanks to our boy Dave dismalchen uh but
um speaking of Dune he was in [__]
dude he won't be in Dune to those
spoilers unless unless there's some
magic Resurrection pills uh
brown shoe sanchu
um let's let's say let's say let's
let's save it because I have a feeling
that like
if we talk about Indiana Jones and the
dial of Destiny we'll want to go to
something positive after
exactly forecasting where we're going
yeah we yeah we didn't really talk about
it but
I you know I I figure I I can't predict
where Mark's gonna go but I have a good
idea
um
we saw Indiana Jones in the dire Destiny
kids we didn't see it together
um I saw it at smart Castle Cinemas you
could see it there for like 10 [__]
bucks or less on a Tuesday
um I watched it with a crowd we did a
watch with Kev screening
uh just to give you some background on
my relationship with this movie I saw
the very first Indiana Jones movie
Raiders of the Lost Ark in a goddamn
movie theater with my father
with my [__] sainted father
um he took uh me on a one of our first
Wednesday movie date
um when uh my mom when I was a kid my
mom told my dad you got to start doing
some [__] with these kids
like they're growing up fast mailman
worked at the post office late nights so
he'd sleep through most of the day
and so uh she was like you got you're
gonna miss their childhood man you're
you're in Cats in the Cradle this
[__] right here
Harry Chapin's song was huge on the
radio I'm sure my mom heard it and she
was like don't don't let this happen to
you
and so my old man was like well
that one likes movies maybe I'll take
him to the movies and that became our
thing so we went to see Raiders the Lost
everybody
we
the only thing we I knew about it was
Han Solo was in it
um
but I told this story all the time my
father was a pretty quiet dude you know
and we didn't have like the relationship
I had with my kid like me and my kid are
like buddies friends and [__]
um me and my dad he was my dad you know
it's just
I didn't he didn't he didn't wear as
hard on his sleeve and [__] like that he
wasn't like incredibly open like I am
you know he was his dad [__] back in
the 70s in the 80s you had a [__]
parent like you weren't like well again
how do you feel and [__] like that like
you do or you're in trouble and whatnot
so you know I didn't I didn't I knew him
as my dad I didn't know who he was right
I just knew him as like a disciplinarian
the guy who went to work the guy we had
to be quiet when he was sleeping because
[__] you know sleep was so precious
since he worked at night and [__]
so we go to see Raiders of the Lost Ark
and that was the day that I met not my
father but Don Smith the GUI Center at
the heart of my dad the little boy who
loved [__] movies and [__] because
we're watching this Raiders the law
start moving about 20 [__] minutes
into this picture
my old man is on the edge of his seat I
mean he was there from the beginning but
like he's on the edge of his seat and he
is like [__] dialed into this [__]
movie all wide-eyed [__] way more
attentive than he ever was to me as a
parent in his entire [__] life he was
like all over this movie and he was so
excited [__] he was like engaged he
was talking my father didn't really like
talk a lot you know my sister accuses me
of stealing Silent Bob from my dad but
that day oh my God you couldn't shut him
up he was just like isn't this great oh
my God they're making movies like the
movies I used to go to when I was a kid
they called him Cliffhangers me and your
Aunt Barbara would go and we paid 50
cents and you'd see a movie and they
would end but then you had to come back
the next week to see what happened this
is amazing they're making Cliffhanger is
this great I'm having a great time are
you having a great time it was like he
had been doing [__] rails before we
went
and you learn a lot about a [__]
sitting next to him in the dark watching
movies and that's where I learned the
most about my my father you know that
was something that when I had a kid I
was like I'm not gonna let my kid figure
out who I am based on you know [__]
the things I like I'm going to be more
open with my kid my dad came from a
different school of thought than that
but when I went to the movies with him
that's where he opened up and I got to
see who he really was
and so Raiders of the Lost Ark is a is a
thick part
of the DNA of why I love movies in
general
um because not only are they fun and
entertaining and they beat Sports and
[__] it you know I'd rather watch a
movie than [__] do almost anything in
the world
but the movies gave me my dad like my
best look at who my dad really was as a
person as opposed to just like father
like oh he likes some of the [__] out
like that's why I love going to the
movies still to this day that's why I
love the movies that I love you know
some people like how could you like the
[__] flash I was like because it
reminds me of the movies that I would go
see with my father escapism he loved
that [__] my father wasn't like let's go
see a documentary you know he loved
action movies and whatnot
so
when I you know every Indiana Jones
movie let me say I saw Raiders with him
I saw a temple of doom with them I saw
um Last Crusade with him and I didn't
see crystal skull with him he'd he'd
pass by that point
um
and so going into this one
you know every time I go to the movies
it's a chance
to see my dad again for a few seconds
right like you know if you get lost in
the joy of emotion picture and whatnot
there's always a good chance that like
I'm gonna feel them there you know like
oh [__] dad would have loved this I say
that [__] all the time my father would
have loved this movie
um you know like I know a lot of people
[__] all over cop out you know who would
have been the biggest [__] cop-out
fan on the planet my father and not
because I made it uh because my father
was never like the kind of guy that was
like you could do anything you want but
if you put your mind to it he wasn't one
of those like TV parents or anything
like that in fact when I got a career my
father was the kind of [__]
would often be like you know I'd be like
oh my God we got a great review in the
New York Times he's like yeah but did
you see the Asbury Park Press review
my father kept it real I think and would
never let me get too big for my [__]
britches and [__] like that but cop out
oh he would have combed his pants man he
loves [__] cop movies funny cop
movies [__] like quasi-action flicks
he loved Bruce Willis and [__]
so whenever I go to the movies it's an
opportunity to visit with the guy who
hasn't been around in 20 years and a
version of the guy who hasn't been
around in like 40 years or something
like that you know a certain point
sadly I stopped going to the movies with
my dad and started going to the movies
with my friends and [__] like later
on with my wife and kids and kid sorry
and um you know at a certain point
I can't even tell you the last movie I
went to with my father and I don't want
to get all emotional and [__] because I
already take a lot of [__] for crying on
the internet but
you know I
I wish
I wish I I had I'd seen more movies with
them later in life I spent my childhood
going to the movies with a guy and I
wish I'd spent a better portion of my
adulthood doing it once I became a
filmmaker
um you know
I didn't I didn't get to go to the
movies with him a lot I'd see movies
early or and then you know you get
married and you [__] like seeing
movies with your wife and stuff
so when I go to the movies now and part
of the reason I own the movie theater
that I do my hometown theater where I
grew up is because I went to that
theater a lot with my dad and just going
to the movies always gives me a chance
to bring my dad back
so
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny
definitely had moments where I was like
my dad is here
um
[Music]
then there were moments where I was like
boy I hope my dad likes this more than I
do
um you know I'm sure he would have I'm
sure my dad would have been nuts for
this movie where he's like oh he's old
now that's awesome
um I
I this I I rarely do this man
but I came
in for a different movie than the one we
got
um you got yourself the dial of Destiny
right which I didn't I never heard about
until this [__] movie but the idea
spoilers and kids lots of spoilers as we
talk about this
you know the idea is like this dial of
Destiny could find a rift in time
so you can enter that [__] Rift and
essentially time travel
you know now that seems a little like
far-fetched for an Indiana Jones movie
but thanks to Crystal Skull he met
aliens like the sky's the limit at this
point Raiders and lost star I mean you
know I I anybody that's like all these
movies are getting too ridiculous it's
like hey man at the end of Raiders of
the Lost Ark like the [__] angel of
death of God comes out of the [__]
Ark of the Covenant and [__] strips
Nazis faces and melts them and [__] so
they've always been
you know an air of fantasy to them you
know [__] Temple of Doom [__]
reaches in and pulls hearts out and
shows it to people and [__]
um and then in Indiana Jones the Last
Crusade
I you know he meets a [__]
thousand-year-old man
at one point who's been watching a
[__] cup so there are always elements
of like wow man it starts rooted in
reality and then goes into you know some
flights and fancy and he eloquently
talks about in in dial of Destiny I've
you know I've seen some [__] and [__]
I can't quote it verbatim but you know
something that effective like doesn't
matter what you believe in
it's how hard you believe or some said
[__]
so you know there have always been
moments in this franchise where things
go from he's an archaeologist a man of
science into facing some [__] that
science can't explain and that's part of
the joy and the fun of these flicks
so I was there for the concept of
Indiana Jones going back in time or
going anywhere in time
where they took him
and when they took him there
to me I'm like you could tell any story
in the world especially if you're doing
this dial a destiny thing
hey get that [__] built in the first
hour and then spend the next hour hour
and a half letting this [__] jump all
around in time he's an archaeologist
he's [__] talked about different eras
throughout all the movies what I thought
was gonna happen was and and this was
based on Dr Josh Roush you know I worked
with did wrong reasons which is coming
out in mid-august on home video
streaming but he does Hollywood Babylon
with us and stuff
um he said at one point when he first
saw the trailer he's going I bet that
they're going to use the dial of Destiny
to bring him back through all of his
movies and I was like
yes yes oh my God I don't give a [__] if
it's fan service if you're gonna use the
dawn of Destiny to take him back to the
boulder scene take them back to mola Ram
take a like take me on a greatest hits
Journey that's how you end this [__]
franchise with him going back through
the franchise or something like that
and I am that don't happen at all
at all they use the dial of Destiny once
and it happens in the third Act and
where they go was like
you know the [__] clouds part and
you're like where are they and then
you're like
oh
yeah I guess this is a place to go
um Ernie smartcastle keeper Ernie
O'Donnell who is perhaps the biggest
Indiana Jones fan on the planet
he expressed it best after after I saw
the flux he watched it at smodcast
before
it opened one rare opportunity where
it's like he's the co-owner in the place
and he [__] brought his wife and had
a movie date and [__] and he had a blast
he was like he was amazing it was just
us in the theater my theater and we got
to watch the movie and [__]
but he said it best and it [__] has
been plaguing me ever since
he's going why wouldn't why wouldn't
they let him go back and have an
adventure with Professor Ravenwood
Marion's father who we heard about in
Raiders and that's how he met Marion
where she was like I was just a child
which is creepy you know but
like right then and there I'm like
that's I'd [__] pay cash money to see
that that version of Indiana Jones the
dial of Destiny where he actually goes
back in the past and [__] with a
character we never met but have heard
about and we know is important to who he
became
um he's fighting Nazis
which you know if you're checking boxes
yay Nazis are good to fight you beat the
[__] out of Nazis is a great thing man
they did it in The Blues Brothers I
watched that on Sunday night man the
[__] audience went nuts applauding
when the [__] blues mobile chases the
Nazis into into the water and the
Illinois Nazis and stuff so they're the
worst they're the worst I hate Illinois
Nazis
um him beating up Nazis [__] they did it
check that box him wearing the Hat yes
check that box he did it a bunch and
[__]
um they brought back spoilers again they
brought back Salah but we all knew that
from the trailer
but I was kind of hoping that they'd
bring back Short Round
they didn't and it really felt like they
could have particularly because he had a
big year
and you know it's not like they were
done making this movie until like 10
minutes ago so it feels like they could
have got him in there and and I know
like you're never supposed to review a
movie that wasn't made right you're
supposed to talk about the one that they
did make but that was kind of the
problem for me is like
they could have made
so many other different movies than the
than the one they did and I know a lot
of people online are going after Phoebe
Waller bridge I didn't have a problem
with her I like fleabags so I think
she's talented I didn't bump into that
at all he's always had you know some
woman that he's fighting with and [__]
like that
um
it was just what they chose to do with
the storyline
was like that that just kind of left me
like oh all right and what they did was
fine I'm not saying like it's dog [__]
no it's incredibly well made James
mangled is an insanely talented
filmmaker
um it just and I'm not saying the
writers [__] up I'm just saying like I
wish it had been something
different and I think I felt that about
Crystal Skull back in the day but I've
rewatched Crystal Skull in the course of
the last year and realized that I slept
through a good half hour of it the first
time I saw it
I was like when did he meet
amps and then [__] Josh Robbs
watching with me he's like what are you
talking about I was like I guess I fell
asleep during that part
so you know I there was nothing wrong
with Indiana Jones and the dial of
Destiny
um better than the Indiana Jones movie I
could ever make sure
but I just wish that it was his last
adventure they're saying and chances are
based on the box office this is it
you know
I just wish
they've done something else did he ever
meet Dr Ravenwood and young Indiana
Jones
I don't know
when Ernie said that that cracked my
world in half I was like
I would love to see that [__] movie
this is the guy who shaped who he became
and you know introduced him to the
[__] woman that would he would love
for the next for for a movie years later
in the first movie and then [__] nothing
about her in the second nothing about
her in the third and then in the fourth
movie that they made 16 years ago or 15
years ago she was back and and spoilers
you know there's there's a Marion
storyline in this one as well
but that to me would have been [__]
what a what a good move that would have
been and honestly like Josh and Ernie
came up with two better versions of the
movie that I was really hoping it could
have been particularly like I saw an
early trailer or we all saw a trailer
where there was a boulder at one point
that that's not in this movie at all
unless I fell asleep and I don't think I
fell asleep but that Boulder does not
appear in this [__] movie so what
happened there
um you know it's
worth seeing because it's Indiana Jones
and Harrison Ford is
wonderful the whole opening you know
sequence where they de-age him I didn't
bump into the CG some people are
complaining about that CG doesn't good
or bad CG I'm kind of indifferent too it
doesn't matter to me but if you're gonna
make a guy look young
like do something to his voice too you
know that's what they did with Luke
Skywalker right like they [__] young
them up but they also younged up his
voice so you know when first when they
take the hood off Indy and he's young
indie
you know you're like hey [__] not bad
man and then he talks and you're like
wait a second
that sounds like the voice of a senior
man right there
um so uh you know my expectations were
not [__] high it wasn't like because
of my dad this movie had to be great no
not by any stretch the imagination
but I think it gets by on a lot of
Goodwill because of my relationship with
my father
um I think it's watchable and I think
it's again I think everyone involved
equips themselves well it's not like
anybody dropped the [__] ball or they
suck at their job
but for the last adventure
I you know I just I would have
if I were in charge of the studio or
whatever the [__] like Ernie at one
point asked me
he goes in your business
did they ever
like do polls or market research or just
talk to the fans
and I was like
I don't I said number one I'm not in
that business I don't know what the [__]
they do over there I said but like I'm
when I'm I'm always in connection with
the fan base all two of them so like I
[__] I'm I'm dialed into like what
people want to see or blah blah blah but
it does seem like
nobody cares you know what I'm saying it
does feel like
there's a sense of like well I don't
give a [__] with the audience wants I'm
gonna tell the story I want to tell and
that's fine for your first time out
maybe even your second time now but when
you're building a franchise which is all
predicated on fan [__] service right
shouldn't you [__] ask the public
what they want maybe just be like hey
man what kind of like I would have
gotten 100 Indiana Jones fans in a room
and be like what story would you like to
see
um because
the problem that they face with this
this ain't Star Wars where you know Star
Wars you could introduce a young
generation and keep the old generation
you need to grassy the Next Generation
that [__] they tried that a little bit
of Kingdom the Crystal Skull and Shia
LaBeouf and whatnot but
they've completely let that go I don't
know if that had something to do with
Shia himself being trouble or
problematic or some such [__] but you
know spoilers he ain't in this movie and
there's a moment where you're like all
right now he is gonna be in the movie
and that would have worked for me like
in the third act and [__] when he comes
back and [__] that's when you know
spoilers spoiler spoilers spoilers
Marion shows up I was like okay next
month's gonna come through the door even
though he wasn't like my [__]
favorite character or whatever the [__]
at least that would have made it like
worth the journey that Indiana Jones had
to go on but
it's kind of a movie about grief
and I'm all for it Clark's three is a
movie about [__] grief but you know
clerks 3 is also not the fifth movie in
a [__] popcorn franchise that you
would imagine Disney wants to keep going
like there was talk at one point of you
know Chris Pratt is going to be the next
Indiana Jones or anybody but now they
seem to have dropped that all together
and somebody asked me during the Q a
afterwards they're like do you think
they're gonna continue this one day
without him and I was like I don't know
he is the franchise it's not like Star
Wars where it's like you know
you got droids and Wookies and Darth
Vader and so they're ageless right you
know as long as you can make a mask
[__] those characters will always be
as exactly as old as you want to be now
that they have James Earl Jones voice
Darth Vader can say [__] from now until
the end of time
um
he he is the whole [__] franchise
he's the only unifying threat of all of
those movies
um and I you know
it's not like James Bond where
you know the last James Bond movie took
place like two weeks ago it's not like
we have to go back into the past all
these movies take place in the bygone
era and they're centered around one guy
they've never done a you know in this
this year Indiana Jones is in the
present it's all predicated on on the
past so I I don't know if they'll ever
try this guy I don't know maybe like
years from now if he passes if he ever
passes maybe they'll be like no maybe
we'll try it with somebody else but you
see he is the franchise he is but like I
mean my
practically like business mercenary wise
look look at like Disney does not buy
lucasfilm and then leave this just
sitting on the shelf for that long
um I think it'll be years I think it'll
be five maybe ten years until they try
it again but you know it's like it's the
Captain Kirk of it right like for the
longest time where I was like it's
always got to be shot in there it's got
to be shattering there's nobody else is
gonna play Captain Kirk until somebody
else played Captain Kirk you're like oh
all right well yeah let's give this a
roll
I do think at some point we'll see
another Indie
um and it's still got to be period
because to your point like Indiana Jones
and cell phones doesn't make any sense
um
but that's just me sorry to cut you off
no not at all
um yeah I I mean I'm I'm like sure
anything could be rebooted but he does
seem to be
he has always been
the franchise
um yeah I just you know I don't want
anyone thinking like I hated this movie
not by any stretch of the imagination
um but you know if somebody asked me
afterwards like how do you rank them
and I ranked them in the order they came
out like used to be when I was a kid I
love [__] Temple of Doom even more
craters but the older I got it kind of
go Raiders Temple of Doom Last Crusade
Crystal Skull
of Destiny
um and that doesn't mean like each
diminished in quality is just that's
personal preference that's the order I
like the order they came out in oddly
enough is the order
that I like them in as well
um I understand what they were going for
you know
um the bad guy mads Mickelson who plays
every villain ever now
um you know is trying to go back in time
and [__]
right the wrongs of Adolf Hitler he's
not trying to help him spoilers
ultimately he wants to kill him
um
but
you know and and
there's some level of like you have to
accept how things are not the way they
were or whatever I guess might be a
theme that's running through it
um you know I just and and I guess I'm
sure there are a lot of Sunny East which
would be like you're a [__] [__] for
wanting fan service but
I don't know man if you're making if
you're you're making the fifth in a
series you're counting on people who
liked the original ones to come back Am
I Wrong was that crazy
shouldn't you be playing to those cats
you know I don't I don't know but anyway
totally worth seeing what are your
thoughts
um I uh
I I
was disappointed more than I was angered
angry you know it wasn't like gosh screw
you for wasting two and a half hours out
of my life [__] uh if I [__] everybody
had anything to do with this movie it
wasn't that
um but I I
it is one of those movies where you can
all the pieces were there in kind of the
wrong order
you know like they had the building
blocks that they needed for one of those
you know and I had never thought about
the the
Ernie solution of the Ravenwood or the
Josh rash solution of the time travel
through
Indy's greatest hits
but it did feel as if to your point it
wanted to be a movie about grief and
Recovery right like it wanted to be a
movie about you know you meet Indiana
Jones at you know I guess at this point
he's 80 years old about to retire from
teaching it's a New York University that
is not nearly as prestigious as
whatever the earlier one that he you
know that seemed like it was in
Cambridge Massachusetts that felt very
ivy league now is it like Hunter College
you know teaching to students who don't
give a [__]
um and then in crashes and Adventure
that it felt like the movie wanted to
show us a Indiana Jones being rekindled
by Adventure
that something had happened to him that
broke him and by going on this journey
with his goddaughter
um it it it reignites what made Indiana
Jones special you know both as for
viewers both as a character both
internally in the story as a human
person right so then when you get to the
point at the end of the movie spoilers
when you know Marion shows up Marion who
has also been crushed by grief
you know but was looking
um to Indiana Jones was looking to her
husband was looking to her partner to
help pull her out of it to to be a
beacon to be something to be present so
they could share that grief
um she asks him are you back
and the answer you want to have as a
viewer is to have seen him claw his way
back to have seen him take some joy in
anything do you see him smile once at
anything and anybody and he kind of
doesn't throughout the movie it's a
relatively joyless movie
um
I I was desperately hoping that the dial
of Destiny would be itself the magic of
the world you know and not like GPS to a
thing in the sky that we have no control
over that seems to be wonky that that
ultimately does not answer what Indiana
Jones's stated problem is like there's a
sequence when when Helena Shaw played by
Phoebe Waller Bridge
and asks him if you could time travel
Indy what would you do and again
spoilers were spoiling this movie by now
he says I'd go back and I'd stop my son
from enlisting in the army
I'm like oh all right now I know what
we're doing time travel he's going to go
back in time and stop his son from
joining the Army and then he'll have to
make a choice like Indiana Jones always
has some kind of choice to make
do I stop this from happening and
potentially destroy history as we know
it or do I save my son
and damn history to the to the to the
wins like scientist versus father what
choice do I make
it's not that at all then it's oh hey
we're gonna go back into like 1939 and
like punch more Nazis oh all right is
Indiana Jones going to want to [__]
kill Hitler huh
all right let's do that then and then
have to choose between saving you know
Untold numbers of lives or ruining the
course of history all right [__] it I
get that but to do what we did
doesn't answer anybody's story
emotionally
you know
um
I don't understand the relationship to
his goddaughter Helena you know in that
like in and Phoebe wallerbridge is
playing a relatively quote unquote
unlikable character I don't need
characters to be likable that's not what
I'm there for
I just kind of need to understand why
they do what they do and what they want
and it is never clear what she wants in
relation to Indiana Jones
there's a version of that story where
Indiana Jones is her Godfather Indiana
Jones and her dad have a blistering
fight over the antidra whatever the name
of that machine is
um
and at the end of that fight her father
dies basil Shaw heart attack broken
heart call it whatever you want to call
it Indiana Jones leaves doesn't know
that never goes to the funeral never
goes back never sees his goddaughter
again
who raises that kid right like clearly
she's now an orphan clearly she makes a
bunch of bad decisions and clearly
there's a version of this where she
resents Indiana Jones for not being the
father that she should have been he
should have been for her in the same way
he was never the father he should have
been for mutt like the ongoing you know
the serial issue with Indiana Jones is
he's never there when you need him to be
there unless you're from something a
thousand years ago and so like then it
becomes a movie about reconnection to
the world reconnection to the surrogate
child he left behind reconnection to the
wife that you left behind reconnection
to everything
it's not that you know it's it's it just
nudges up against these ideas that seem
like they were interesting and then does
the version that is not
the version that doesn't emotionally
invest you the version that that just
kind of skitters on the surface
and
doesn't doesn't make you want to watch
more of it
um
you know and like
and I watch crystal skull over the
weekend because I hadn't seen that movie
in a decade maybe even more I remember
hating it because of course we all hated
it because it wasn't Last Crusade
but at least you know that's kind of an
Indiana Jones movie there's some fun in
that movie there's some there's some
bounce in that movie you know sure the
aliens are ridiculous and none of that
really makes sense and
you know Shia LaBeouf is Shia LaBeouf
and either you [__] with him or you
don't I don't particularly so that was a
lot of character and an actor that I
don't know [__] with that much
but I got it you know when Marion shows
up it's fun again there's some really
interesting action scenes at Spielberg
who's never placed the camera in the
wrong place his whole career like it
works and this movie just kind of feels
joyless it feels perfunctory it feels
like we had to make an indie movie so
this is the movie we made
as opposed to you know drilling down
either with fans present either with
just people present or whatever what
makes us love this character what's the
best way to send this character off
you know what's the what's the mo how do
we honor
who Indiana Jones has been for the last
40 years
and I'm not sure if this movie was
designed to answer those questions or to
be there for for an audience who wanted
one last ride with this guy
and that's ultimately was just
disappointing it was just like yeah I
mean it's not awful I mean the CG is
whatever the CG is I've seen bad CG I've
seen good CG there's no story reason for
that opening 20 minutes
like other than to establish a father
you're going to kill off like Helena
Shaw could have been Helena Brody
right like Marcus Brody's kid yeah who
that's what I thought when I first saw
the trailer and he was like this is my
goddaughter I was like oh [__] that's
gonna be Marcus Brody's kid that would
make a lot more sense a ton more sense
like
90 people are going to tell us about the
[__] Antica fera anyway so we don't
need that sequence that that opens the
movie
and you know parentheses the [__] the
Spear of longinus maybe a better you
know McGuffin to have the chase down
um but like there's just yeah and the
the lack of Short Round is is so weirdly
flummoxing it's like you have these
characters that that crashed into the
movie don't do anything die suddenly
like Antonio Banderas is there for 15
minutes to say oh hey Andy how are you
and then gets shot
Boyd Holbrook seems to exist just to
shoot people he almost gets no lines so
crazy there was a lot of him [__]
shooting people in this movie yeah like
and I like Boyd Holbrook like he's a
very talented actor
um but like there's no explanation why
he's there what he's doing why some
weird guy from Alabama is working for
Nazis in the 60s when nobody wanted to
work for Nazis but he's like strapping
in to do whatever and then
you know the weird wanted murder of what
seemed to be Foxy Brown like they were
setting up this whole idea that like oh
all right so this CIA agent this black
woman in the 60s and it's [__] black
exploitation just before and she's
badass and she's gonna she presents as
an antagonist but she's gonna flip sides
and make a turn and then be an ally for
Indy and no we're not doing any of that
for reasons that seem to escape
everybody like it's it is it is an oddly
slap Dash kind of movie that doesn't
invest in the things that the audience
would like to be invested in and then
just throws things at you that don't
really pay off in any in any real way
and so yeah it was just like huh
okay I mean I suppose
I suppose this is it it does not give
Indiana Jones A better ending than
Crystal Skull gave him
you know which is I'm reunited with this
woman who I've always been in love with
you know we've we've checked a lot of
boxes when it comes to to lore and like
hey we just saw where they have the the
[__] Arc of the Covenant in here hey
we just did this bit hey we just we we
showed Marcus Brody statue at the
University that he was the dean of like
we're giving you these little Easter
eggs these little harmonizing points for
you and the franchise and then we're
telling a new story which yes aliens
probably not quite right but it is fun
it's fun and this movie Never Felt fun
to me
[Music]
um
yeah well let's hear from a guy who
who's got a thing or two to do with
[__] with this film Lucas has nothing
to do with lucasfilm
uh I actually bumped into Mark walking
into the movie so we did see it at the
same time in the same theater
um
I felt almost like it was a different
movie like they tried to make a punch
shooting action movie where I always
thought Indiana Jones was an adventure
movie
like this had no Adventure like Indiana
Jones does not solve a single puzzle
there's no stay out of the light moment
there's no running away from a bolder
moment there's no x marks the spot
moment there's no Breath of God penitent
man will pass there's no puzzles in the
entire movie it's in it's like young
Indiana Jones
the last resort was using his fist the
first resort was using his brain and for
some reason 80 year old Indiana Jones
his first Resort is using his fists and
then in a two and a half hour movie
there doesn't seem to be any time for
him to use his brain
and the only time I smiled in the whole
movie was when Saul is like and I'm
going with you and then Indiana Jones is
like no go drive your cab
and and then I thought Salah was gonna
show up and save him like he did in
other movies and he didn't he just drove
a cab
and he's like what is going on here it
was
so
and why was the CIA and then there was a
David Bowie needle drop in it which felt
really weird which I guess in Temple of
Doom they they have anything goes
but like there's not
like music like that like John Williams
is the music of of Indiana Jones and
like
this had David Bowie at the beginning
which I get it like space in the 60s but
also like what I don't know I did yeah
there's that sequence when uh when you
know your bad guys are all on that plane
and they're like who is this guy who is
this Dr Jones and then they hand
somebody at dossier
and then they never read it
because that doctor would be like oh
this guy he got medals in World War II
and he [__] survived all kinds of
encounters with us like the file for
Indiana Jones
ought to be like the best reading in the
world and nobody seems to know that this
guy used to be a [__] Avenger for
Christ's sake and it just yeah you know
he's old what could he possibly know how
dangerous could he possibly be and there
ought to be that scene where somebody's
like you guys
he [__] punched Hitler in the face
you guys he this guy got nuked in a
fridge yeah he's been shot a dozen times
a lot of people are saying in chat the
water displacement grave answers JC's
question but I I mean that's one thing I
guess but they also didn't so that
wasn't a puzzle that was solved he was
just like oh by the way once upon a time
in a book I read Archimedes liked water
and he dropped like it wasn't
like Indiana Jones you were always one
step of behind Indiana Jones on the
adventure right Indiana Jones new ex
marked the spot before you did India you
saw the light in writers of the Lost Ark
you you registered it and then Indiana
Jones told you stay out of the light and
then it paid off later when
uh Alfred Molina doesn't stay out of the
light right like there was none of that
it was like the the adventures were
dictated to you it didn't feel like an
adventure it felt like a
like a parent telling you not to do this
thing like even like there was no
reasoning Indiana Jones picked up the
tablet and he's like oh this is too
heavy to be wax but there was no like
lead up to that you had no opportunity
as an audience member to like
be like why are they having such a hard
time picking this thing up like there is
nothing also if you wanted to do deep
cut fan service have Indiana Jones lose
his eye
because in the young Indiana Jones
Chronicles 90 year old Indiana Jones
only has one eye he wears an eye patch
and that could have been like a real
good deep cut for like people who really
love the franchise
John Mathers in chat said Easter eggs
referencing the past are only good for
fans
who the [__] were they making the movie
for
you make the fifth in a series this is
not like you know Martin Scorsese doing
a movie about the mob again this is a
direct [__] sequel
and they need fans to go he also said
movies should use easy Easter eggs to
reference future plots arcs and
characters to generate mystery Nostalgia
will only generate so much money
good this whole [__] movie was about
Nostalgia the whole trip is about
Nostalgia like that's the only way this
is this thing's gonna do any business
like
also Marvel has made a career of
spending an hour of a two and a half
hour movie setting up the next movie and
they're not pulling tons of box office
Ant-Man like they used to either yeah I
mean there's there's the shitty way to
use Nostalgia and then there's the the
the harmonious way to use Nostalgia
Creed is a very nostalgic movie like it
will give you little Easter eggs whether
you recognize them or not they will be
like hey I don't know what these flag
shorts are from if you know and it's
like oh [__] are those Apollo shorts the
shorts that Apollo died in when when
[__] Rocky didn't save his life like
the music cues are all Nostalgia like
you can you can deploy that stuff to
Advanced story and character it's and so
there's a version of this well yeah you
got a couple Easter eggs you got a
couple of nostalgic you know beats that
remind you why you loved Indiana Jones
that remind you why you know and remind
you the depth of his story
and then yeah for sure you could have
him just walk past the the Raves Lost
Ark you know the Lost Darkness like wig
wink at it be like next time baby we're
coming back for you like nobody needs
that but it's a tool and in the right
hands it can be great in the wrong hands
it's just that
Victor Venn diagram and chat it raises
an excellent point he goes Raiders was
Nostalgia it was Lucas's love letter to
the old pulp Adventure short movies
absolutely right this thing has always
been steeped in in nostalgia
somebody also said Kevin calm down I
don't even know what they're [__]
talking about like you know they said
how dare you not love a thing how dare
relax Kevin and I was like when was I
not [__] relaxed
why do I read chat
because sometimes people say interesting
things like that there it is
yeah so yeah like it's it's just it's a
missed opportunity
you know and red comet said young
Indiana Jones won six Emmys is that true
wow didn't surprise me
um probably for like VFX and score like
you know the craft categories that one
can win enemies for
um I don't know if it's ever nominated
for for writing or acting or directing
or anything but
the VFX stuff on that show was way ahead
of its time
is that right yeah yeah they were doing
like crowd scenes you know like complete
CG rendered like oh here it's the Third
Reich and you would just see hundreds of
people and like the Peter Jackson
Innovations hadn't really took place yet
so it was just ilm cranking on that [__]
and did amazing work
um yeah so there it is
yeah kids go see it
[Laughter]
three old people don't like the movie
who grew up with the movie but you
should go see it anyway I would hesitate
to say I don't like it it just you know
look everybody should be seeing things
and judging for themselves and if you
don't go see it in theaters and whatnot
or it's mod castle for 10 months
um you know see it and catch up to it
eventually but don't don't let anybody
else tell you what the movie is
Indie fever catch it
um let's talk about
um
somebody shouted at me in caps you're
disappointed
um Mark said he was disappointed like he
literally used that term I did
um
let's see
uh let's talk about Dave Desmond's movie
so yeah Dave Desmond is in a movie and
it's made by I'm gonna pull the
director's names up
because I don't I don't want a couple of
us Australian guys right yeah I'm not
gonna say they're first timers or
something but directors Colin and
Cameron Cairns
um the movie is called late night with
the Devil
and it is a like period piece set in the
70s and it's like it's played kind of
like a found footage film but not like
uh you know Blair Witch or some say [__]
like that it's more like these are the
reels of this talk show the night this
horrible thing
happened
right
um the live television event that
shocked a nation says the poster they've
dismalchen plays a TV talk show host
um that's you know it's always second to
Carson can't quite crack the tonight
shows uh
um ratings
and um it deals in in like in 70s a cult
which plays a huge part in the storyline
Satanism occultism
um
uh possession it it's it honestly it's
like somebody when he first told me
about it like last year
I was like oh my God that sounds like
somebody [__]
made my dream movie
and then I saw it and it is very much
like this movie checks so many boxes for
me and does so many things
that a young version of me and the old
ass version of me
[__] totally
appreciates and would have appreciated
like as I watched this movie one of the
first things I thought is like you know
who's gonna love this movie is Walt
Flanagan
um
it's just so [__]
[__] [__] up in 70s it looks like a
period piece looks like it literally was
shot in the [__] 70s
um the production value the concept is
great because like I you could literally
since it's shot on a stage like it's you
know the budget didn't have to be
[__] exorbitant right because there's
a place on a talk show and [__]
um and Dave plays the lead and he plays
the talk show host Jack what's his name
Jack I can't remember I think the show's
called Night Owl or something yeah like
I saw it at the Overlook Film Festival
um it was it was I want to say the
closing night film it definitely it had
its World premiere there
um and so it was a couple months back
but I I also was struck by like the low
budget smartness of it yes which is like
hey guys all we have to do is recreate a
set and a dressing room
um and we don't even have to dress this
Sound Stage very much because half of
it's behind the scenes so you can have
the walls be dry and the lighting
hanging from the rafters and everything
and
I mean it in the grand scheme of of
having to pay to produce and recreate a
feel this is a relatively cheap thing to
have to recreate
um you're almost never outside the
studio I mean it's a documentary thing
so they do have like you know there
there's the footage of the Lost
broadcast of the Night Owl show which
they then sort of intersperse with some
documentary stuff with a little bit of
interview stuff with some like news
really things with some voice over
but you know the bulk of it is just in
that space
and and yeah and Dave is the center of
it and doing a thing that we've never
really seen him do before yeah because
he's so often cast because you know he's
got a very specific look and a very
specific Vibe sometimes it's creepy
sometimes it's off kilter sometimes it's
just weird
but he's being intentionally charismatic
you know he's being the kind of guy who
would hosts the Late Night show a little
smarmy a little large a little funny
um and I've never seen him do that stuff
before and so it's just really great to
watch him kind of stretch his legs
leading man like yeah he carries the
movie
um I love the [__] flick I thought it
was so badass and unsettling and [__]
creepy and [__] uh not too long either
because you know it's a
that by the time the movie ends you're
like [__] and and you could watch more
of it but it doesn't feel like they cut
it short
um
it's
[__] it's good like it's
original although it's made of very
familiar elements very it's honestly
it's like Rosemary's Baby meets Network
um wonderful films that that have been
now uh blend together into late night
with the devil
um I don't know when it's coming out but
[__] like
really
really [__] turned my crank
um and and in terms of the low budget
smartness of it like as the guy who made
clerks which is like I'm gonna shoot a
movie here in a convenience store which
you know is like that's our entire set
like I was sitting there kind of very
appreciative of the fact that wow man
like that why I wish I had thought of
doing something like this you could make
a very inexpensive [__] movie The
set's not gonna cost you a gazillion
bucks and since it was the 70s like Mark
said the set doesn't have to look
[__] great it needs to look
like 70s basic yeah
drapes essentially and that allows the
performances and the concept to take
like center stage and there's effects in
it the effects are well done
um they shot it out in Australia
um [__] I love this movie uh I want to
show it it's modcastles like soon as
possible and have Dave come out with it
um I can't normally we could tell you
where to watch a thing but I don't know
when it's coming out yeah I mean I don't
know if it's still in its Festival run
um you know I don't know I don't know if
it has distribution yet or if that was
part of the run to hopefully acquire
distribution
um but it's a really really fun watch
um yes [__] I love this movie I I mean I
don't wanna
I don't want to say too much and spoil
it but it is I'm telling you man it's
like I'm a big fan I was raised Catholic
so I'm a big fan of [__] devil movies
uh and this is a [__] devil movie
um and a 70s devil movie
uh it's in very well done my hat's off
to the filmmakers um and
Dave good old Dave just mulching man
um he
playing playing a lead some you know
Dave's always kind of like the guy
behind the guy behind the guy
or you know a [__] character actor
but he [__] pulls it off in a big bad
way yeah like and if you want to see
Dave the character actor guy behind the
gun like he's also in the last Voyage of
the Demeter which is out in I want to
say Late July
um early August but it's the story of
the ship that took Dracula from
Transylvania to London
and in the in the Bram Stoker book it's
it's like what not even a paragraph It's
a couple sentences like you know the the
coffin of Dracula was loaded onto the
Demeter the X number of days everybody
in the boat was dead when it arrived in
London like that's all that there is in
Bram Stoker's original text but this is
the movie about that Voyage about
[__] Dracula getting out about him
killing everybody like 10 Little Indians
or whatever you want to call and then
there were none which is the the new not
[__] up and racist title of the Agatha
Christie book
um you know it's it's a sort of classic
tale of of killing everybody in
interesting ways and they have this
Mountain's one of the sailors and it's
like yeah [__] it let's do it
um speaking of of uh Dracula did we ever
talk about Renfield did you ever catch
up with Renfield I did I saw it at the
same Festival
the [__] out of that movie
it came and went pretty quick but like I
I caught up with it um at home I I
watched it and
man like Nick Cage as Dracula was
exactly what you were hoping it would be
yeah and that's a cool concept and I
thought the [__] action was cool and
stuff Nicholas hope I thought was good
that was definitely a movie worth seeing
um but yeah man [__]
if you can if it's playing at a festival
go track down late night with the Devil
[__] really great man if you're a fan
of 70s occult satanic movies like [__]
yeah
keep an eye on Davis Mountain socials
like I'm sure once it once it breaks
once it gets it's it's it's released
State and schedule and all that stuff
he'll have it on his Instagram or
Twitter or whatever or blue sky for that
matter
um they uh
um are you I'm not watching uh Superman
and Lois not because I'm like I ain't
watching it but I'm not I haven't kept
up with it but me neither I did watch
um what's his name Michael cut cutlets
yeah as Lex Luthor like they've been
putting the clips up on YouTube holy
[__] yeah really [__] enjoyable like
they're doing a different a very blue
collar Lex Luthor
um and he has a [__] scene on the
porch
of Lois and Clark's house that is
[__] he's he's electric like you know
I know Jon Cryer in the CW Universe was
an excellent [__] Lex Luthor but
Michael cudlitz is doing something
really [__] badass a really Butch
like I wasn't talking to you kind of
[__] excluded
[__] it was good man I don't know if
that was the season finale or whatnot
but I watched all of his scenes
um
on YouTube they've been you know clipped
and put up there and [__] man he
that's it like you know it's big shoes
to fill right you know Gene Hackman and
Clancy Brown [__] who played him in
the Animated World yeah like their their
characterization of a real [__]
hardcore Butch Luthor who like was put
in jail
wrongly quote unquote wrongly imprisoned
and [__] and he's got a [__] beef
with Lois Lane
really [__] cool man I urge to go
check out the scenes on uh
on uh
on YouTube right now or watch the whole
episode if you want yeah that's a show
that I just never like I remember seeing
the pilot and Doug the pilot but just
never never kept up with
um
what else could yeah William Anderson
Chacos he's like the breaking bad
version of Lex
I would [__] go with that yeah it was
it was [__] delightful like to see
this dude
just [__] come in like a lion as Lex
Luthor you know mostly Lex Luthor
cinematically is always portrayed as
you know
smarmy
[__] you know he's got a sense of
humor and [__] Clancy Brown's Lex Luthor
in the in the Superman the animated
series and the Justice League I always I
I really liked Michael Rosenbaum of
course did a wonderful one in uh
Smallville Smallville but man this
[__] like doing Luthor as like this
[__] like coiled spring
rage machine who's more earthy you know
was was pretty this is a
I think that show has been renewed
that would make you tune in if he was in
every episode and [__] like just
being this
shouty [__] like I'm gonna kick your
[__] ass Lex Luthor yeah I think it I
think it was renewed for its final
season
I think
yeah yeah I remember seeing that
speaking of Superman we got some casting
news I know should we dive into some
news yeah let's go go for some news kids
we talked about some stuff we saw and
liked
and loved and and just saw
um now should we hit the smooth sex
summer first that's true good point yeah
take the lead on that one
uh yeah if you haven't heard already
it's smooth sex summer kids when you're
playing in the Summer sun make sure
you're escaped from pubes to bum that's
right this is the summer to keep your
balls cool while still looking hot with
manscaped another sponsor for tonight's
episode of fat man beyond the leaders in
below the waist grooming are making sure
we all have a ball this summer by giving
our pants Partners everything they need
to stay fresh
dive head first into smooth sex Summer
by going to manscape.com for 20 off plus
free shipping with the code fatman20 at
checkout I'm not a ball hair trimmer are
you
uh I've never done that
um but I'm not opposed to it it's just
never occurred to me I plucked a hair
once and it was a real [__] mistake
I'll be honest
so the idea of [__] manscaping makes
a lot more sense the fact that they made
a ball trimmer like in the performance
package 4.0 it's got everything you need
to prepare that summer BOD Man they got
the built the Ultimate Grooming bundle
for your summer grooming their lawnmower
4.0 trimmer features a Cutting Edge
ceramic blade to reduce grooming
accidents thanks to their Advanced Skin
safe technology the lawnmower 4.0 has a
7 000 RPM Motor that's faster than the
moped I used to ride around
a new multi-function on off switch can
engage a travel lock and gives you the
ability to turn the
4000k LED spotlight on and off when
needed for a more precise shave you want
to get in there with laser focus this is
your nuts for Christ's takes you want to
make it right did I mentioned the
trimmer is waterproof too take it to the
beach the lake the shower this razor
will devour even the strongest [__]
pubes
now that you have the perfect haircut
use manscape's Liquid formulations to
keep that freshness even as the hottest
summer barbecues man most importantly
use their prop preserver ball deodorant
to stay cool in the heat took people it
took mankind or Humanity I should say
you know what [__] 10 000 years ago I
get it [__] deodorant for the balls
that makes sense
soothing aloe vera formula it's the best
in the business for below the waist
freshness and this clear drying formula
will keep looking good
and while smelling good manscaped even
threw in two free gifts for their
performance package 4.0 manscape boxers
and the shed travel bag you just put all
your [__] in the shed man wearing
sandals with some nasty toenails during
the summer months well take a look at
the shears 2.0 a luxury nail grooming
kit this kit includes stainless steel
nail cutters tweezers and grooming
scissors with the performance package
your balls will be ready to impress but
make sure you cover the rest
which here's 2.0 and get 20 off plus
free shipping with the code Fatman 20 at
manscape.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping with the code Fatman 20 at
manscape.com and smooth sex summer
gentlemen get on board or get left
behind
we thank the good Folks at manscaped
for a sponsor in the second half of this
here program
up
uh so yeah we do have a a smattering of
news news as we've discussed in the in
these past couple podcasts is getting a
harder to come by and given the lack of
development stuff thanks to the writer
strike the lack of production stuff but
every now and again some [__] slips of
the cracks that we sweep right back up
and deliver unto you for the news
first item James Gunn has found his
Clark Kent and his Lois Lane for his new
Superman flick which is Superman Legacy
which will be out in 2025 maybe actually
almost two years to the day we will see
a new Superman movie
yeah July 11th 2025. if
a long time a long time Gotta Stay Alive
you could use them to save the box
office right [__] now indeed
um so following months of audition tapes
and in-person Screen tests Warner
Brothers and DC Studios have settled on
David Corn sweat uh as Superman slash
Clark Kent well Rachel brajnahan is on
board to play Lois Lane uh now that's
Miss maisel
that is The Marvelous Miss maisel
um I interviewed her once at a Sundance
for IMDb she was absolutely wonderful
um and I've seen her she did an episode
of Saturday Night Live she was really
good
so um when they started talking about
her as Lois Lane I was like yeah I could
see that who is he
um he was in um Pearl the uh the the who
is it Thai West I think made that little
horror movie
um the politician and HBO's we own this
city
um this is his first major leading role
in a major Studio motion picture
um so it's a bit of a blow up for him
yeah Rachel brajnahan uh has an Emmy for
for playing The Marvelous Mrs maisel
um so she's uh she's got a little tin
under her belt and they're both ready to
get into it they're still casting for
Lex Luthor and Jimmy Olsen and Perry
white and so forth and so on the rest of
the the Superman codery of characters
but no they got their they got the big
two
um and then I heard well I don't know if
this is right but I mean look [__]
after the last episode I'm reticent to
say anything did you see how many
[__] news stories came out of like
Kevin Smith said that they went to
Christian now
my [__] Batman in The Flash movie and
like I was like I did not and I went
back and watched our show and it's
literally me going like
you know what I think you know like it's
conjecture they flipped it somebody
clipped it so it was just me saying that
it sounded more like [__] fact or
something like that
um yeah so there were a bunch I had to
go correcting people last week and some
people they ran articles they're like
Kevin Smith clarified and I said Kevin
Smith did not clarify clarifying would
have been that means like I'm I'm uh
making more clear of something I said
Kevin Smith was correcting something
that other people clipped and took
completely out of concept and sold this
[__] fact
um so yeah I gotta be so careful what I
say on this show
the internet is ruining it thanks
internet
always internetting
um they've asked us in chat if we've
seen secret Invasion have you watched it
yet I have not I keep forgetting that
it's on
I'm gonna let a few episodes collect
yeah like I just I remember the the
hubbub about the opening credits
um having been generated by AI which
felt particularly tone deaf for the for
the time it's like read the room for
heaven's sakes yeah
um but I have not checked it out yet and
I mean to I mean to I've just I've been
too I've been too in love with the bear
sue me
um the bear is great is it it bear is
great I mean the first season has maybe
the single most tense episode of
Television that I've ever watched
um
in addition to you know some of the most
lovely moments and TV shows I've ever
watched somebody uh described it as like
a grittier 10 lasso
in that it does give you these deep
emotional moments of kind of Wonder and
joy but it's a lot of [__] shouting
there's a lot of people yelling in a
restaurant kitchen
um but uh but it's great it's great so
yeah we'll get to secret Invasion
because of course we will
um yeah there's a lot of love for the
bear
in chat people are digging it yeah so
good so good we're season two Jazz PDX
says the bear season two is amazing
still can't get over the family dinner
episode or the one after that
yeah I think that's toward the end of
the season
um
but no awesome the bear is amazing the
bear is excellent a lot of big reviews
man I know what I'm doing tonight the
bear the mayor the mayor
um in other news uh apparently
um Dune part 2 might not be the end of
the news Dune Saga
[Music]
he if if all things go the way he'd like
them to go Dean Evil news would like to
cap off the Dune Trilogy by adapting uh
Frank Herbert's sequel novel Dune
Messiah
um Warner Brothers has not green lit it
Warner Brothers does not actually put it
into development yet Warner Brother
seems to be playing a little bit of a
wait and see game
to see if doing part two does the
business it needs to do to justify
spending hundreds more millions of
dollars on a third movie
um
but uh but yeah man like more didn't
even move Doom yeah I'm here for it I
can't wait for part two you tell me it's
gonna be part three [__] a hell yeah
give me that you read all the books
right I've never read all the books I
read dude Messiah I read
um Children of Dune but then there's
another like 10 novels after that that I
that I just did not get into
um
but yeah man like
[__] give it to me give it all to me I
want to live on Iraqis somebody in chats
John Thompson goes how about the idol
Kev
all those nude Lily Rose depth scenes
yeah I my kid was like don't watch the
idol dad
why I mean the whole internet is saying
don't watch it but my kid was like you
know it's you will be freaked out by how
little clothing Lily Rose wears I'm like
yeah I've known her since she was a kid
I don't I don't need that
but they seem to be taking it pretty
hard
yeah it does I I haven't seen it I I
have not seen very much of uh
Sam Levinson's work never really dug
into Euphoria oh I saw an episode of
euphoria and it terrified me made me
feel old as hell
it's like I don't understand this this
is inscrutable to me what happened I
used to be young [__]
um but
uh yeah I interviewed him once it's uh
for IMDb because the five years I
interviewed people for IMDb so I got to
meet a lot of [__] man and um
they it was one he had assassination
Nation
Sundance and they gave me like the cast
but like they wouldn't give me the
filmmaker
and I kept asking the publicist I was
like is the filmmaker not here and
they're like yeah but you've got your
panel and I was like I I know but like
traditionally this is Sundance like I
interviewed the filmmaker as well
chiefly the filmmaker like the you know
yes of course there are actors in these
movies but like it's a Sundance [__]
film festival and I had to literally
cajole them at first they were telling
me no like he's he doesn't do interviews
blah blah
so we're about to like you know I've got
the kids who I'm interviewing from the
movie and there was another guy like
sitting off to the side
and normally the only people in that
room were people who had something to do
with the movies so I asked somebody I
was like who's that and they're like
that's Sam Levinson he's the guy who
made the movie and I was like
I went over to him I was like hey man
like nice to meet you congrats I was
like
do you not want to talk like do you not
like wanna no worries no pressure and he
goes no they told me not to
[__] them and I was like get another
chair for this kid and so I got to
interview him there and stuff and then
so when they made Euphoria a couple
years back or whatever I was like oh
I've met that and I liked assassination
Nation quite a bit
so I was like well I'm gonna watch you
for it and I watched it and I was
you know I was like a [__] 80 year
old man who got lost in the mall
[Music]
if that's how I felt about euphoria that
I'd be terrified
Fair like I know my limits
um our last bit of news is that uh
apparently fresh off of what you and
every other exhibitor are hoping is
going to be a hit film Barbie Greta
Gerwig Israel I'm telling you man I
don't think this is a hot take or
anything but those [__] trailers are
great their marketing campaign is
wonderful the whole idea of like if you
love Barbie this movie's for you if you
hate Barbie it's for you I was like what
a great approach that's pretty cheesy
but I I I'm an unabashed
unabashed on a bad
I unabashedly [__] adore Ryan Gosling
when he does comedy anytime he's on SNL
he [__] slays it man so like him in
this trailer
I think he's hysterical so I'm not
saying like I ain't there for anyone
else but I am chiefly there
to see Ryan Gosling play stupid to play
him it looks so [__] good to me
um but the storyline seems kind of
kind of cool and there's a bit of
poignancy to it you know one trailer uh
this is the last trailer they put out
um but you know uh Kate McKinnon plays a
version of Barbie like there's all these
versions of Barbie but she apparently
plays the one that like kids destroyed
but her hair
and [__] like that it looks good man I
can't wait to see this movie but anyway
what's the news on it yeah Greta Gerwig
is about the Chronicles and [__]
narnies yo
um she is uh confirmed to be attached to
helm 2 movies for Netflix based on The
Chronicles of Narnia by C.S Lewis
um
I mean
like yeah
I guess I also never would have picked
her to be somebody to do Barbie but
apparently she found a way in that's
super interesting so you know [__] it if
she's gonna adapt the mythical Kingdom
that'll only open itself to Young
Warriors with the purest Arts setting a
stage for a war that will also affect
the human world plus [__] a lion as
God
okay
yeah I'm I'm good for her but I'm just
I've never
I've never been a Narnia guy neither was
I like I saw two of those movies I think
um I saw the first one because I mean it
was a big deal when it came out back in
the sort of I guess that was the early
mid-2000s
um
Disney and fox making those giant ass
movies
it wasn't for me like
just not really
I there was a cartoon they did years ago
The Lion The Witch in the wardrobe which
I enjoy but like I you know if I'm gonna
read C.S Lewis it pretty much begins and
ends with the screw tape letters for me
demons man nice devils and [__] not we
British children and God lions
no but I remember that [__] seeing
that cartoon and being like
Jesus Christ they like stabbed this lion
to death you know and I remember I was
young when I saw it my brother was like
well that's supposed to be Jesus and I
was like what
Netflix and I was like how are they
getting away with this [__]
um but yeah I'm not a I'm not a real big
never been a Narnia guy her man her
career is blowing up hell yeah
um and I guess the last bit of news
um you know we it seems as if we're
going to be doing this almost every
episode
um which is the the sort of obituary for
somebody who meant something quite a bit
to us the great Alan Arkin passed away
what a loss man Alan Arkin one of the
greatest actors who ever acted and [__]
I had texted I was texting with Ben
and um I said like you know I always
wanted to work with them
but you know [__] at least you got to
what a legend like because he was in
Argo he's the one that says Argo [__]
yourself
um I love for my version of Fletch that
I was gonna make years ago he was my
Frank ah yeah I've I've always loved
Alan Arkin uh going way back to like I
watched my father cry laughing at the
in-laws when I was a kid Serpentine
Serpentine and also like when he's
spitting where he's like then he's he
just can't like [__] hold himself in oh
my God uh I you know he's what an
amazing [__] actor I'm a huge
Glengarry Glenn Ross fan Boot shoes yes
um he's he was an absolute [__]
Legend and yeah how old was he he was
um 989.
I mean you know that's of course a very
long life but [__] somebody like Alan
Arkin deserves a hundred Little Miss
Sunshine didn't he win the Oscar for
Little Miss Sunshine he did yeah
um he was PV in The Rocketeer
yeah remember he was the you know
[__] the one that helped uh he was a
mechanic dude yeah The Rocketeer [__]
making black he owned me at Deerfield
pv's Airfield he uh he he didn't have a
[__]
like uh he was also remember Wait Until
Dark
yeah where he was like a bad guy
yeah yeah that was him I always confused
that with Robert Blake I always thought
that Robert Blake was waiting so dark
out but now you're right so not again
um yeah Alan Arkin was an absolute
absolute [__] Legend
[Music]
um
somebody said in chat freebie and the
bean absolutely [__] freebie and the
bean
um yes uh in impound impounded
Coda says he was the shrink and Gross
Point Blank absolutely one of my
favorite roles
you ever played he was a bit part in the
movie comparatively but he's he's Martin
blank's shrink
where you know he's just like uh you
want to talk he talks you're a nickel
that finds out you know like when we
meet him in the movie he's like a
reticent psychiatrist a reticent
therapist and then it comes out in their
dialogue that he's like he doesn't want
to continue being his therapist because
he found out that Martin blank is an
assassin
you can't keep talking to you I have to
go now I need to you know I need to
[__] keep talking to the doctor and
he goes plus I know where you live and
he goes now don't do that that's nice
yeah man that sucks it sucks when we
lose of course some Doc Hayes pointed
out he was your Syrian and catch 22.
absolutely
even the voice of the the burgeoning
young wizard schmendrick in The Last
Unicorn
oh my God he I saw recently on Twitter
that he wrote in a letter to Mad
Magazine when they did their parody of
catch 22.
and he wrote a very complimentary letter
it said Alan Arkin Hollywood California
I thought that was adorable uh in chat
they're also pointing to
um
uh they found Julian Sands body the
Warlock himself rest in peace
um he'd been missing for a while oh
somebody said Kenneth Worley said
Kaminsky method was brilliant and Island
Arkham was in that right Michael Douglas
yeah yeah I'll go back and watch that I
haven't seen that but my my in-laws
watched it and they loved it but back to
Julian Sands uh yeah he was hiking some
play and went missing and I guess I'm
baldy I think I just found some remains
and I guess have they I guess they've
identified them as Julian Sands the
story I saw the other day was like it
might be
he disappeared these bones were found or
these remains are found in the same area
where he disappeared so maybe the
internet's meme seems to know that
they've confirmed it
um
the war of the hiking kids talking about
[__] devil movies before warlock was
one of those yeah I loved warlock I like
a great flick and he was wonderful in it
he was in a bunch of other things as
well but more like merchand Ivory stuff
like I think he using like remains of
the day I think classy actor happened to
also do Warlock and stuff
um
rest in peace rest in power both he is
all
him and uh
him and uh the great Alan Ark and Julian
Sands and Eleanor yeah Room with a View
I think that was the big one
oh yeah Naked Lunch
arachnid that's right he was a good
launch as well
yeah it's an Arachnophobia ER Morris and
chat said that Alan Arkin was a founding
he was in the founding cast of Second
City I didn't know that it's fantastic
God that guy was talented I always
wanted to work with him and I never had
the thing
ah man yeah [__]
sucks when people
have to Die Why do why do men die
Julian sins played jorel on Smallville
is that right here
Banff
oh man Brett deakin of 4dx Fame just
texted me that Alan Arkin wrote The
Banana Boat Song the Deo
and so I've looked it up and he is
listed as one of the writers on the
Harry Belafonte
Banana Boat Song
are you kidding me no
Alan Arkin Bob Carey and Eric darling
he's the first listed songwriter on the
Banana Boat Song wow you don't need this
acting money you got banana
there's always money in the banana boat
some Mr tally man uh they pointed out in
chat that Boxing Helena Julian Sands was
in that as well mm-hmm Jennifer
Lynchburg
uh the slickness
says we can't appreciate life without
death I mean I guess but
why why
does there have to be any death can't we
just keep going can't we do can we
regenerate come on we also we all like
Doctor Who
why can't we [__] do it
of all the things I thought I'd never
hear Kevin say we all like Doctor Who
yeah
um [__] Maya yeah [__] man Eleanor well
my dad's been dead for 20 years but he
would have been heartbroken at the death
of Alan Arkin I'm telling you I've never
one of the first times I ever saw him
like split his seams gut-bustingly
laughing was during the in-laws
he was like let's watch that
yeah
it doesn't make me want to watch it
again well [__] it just sounds like an
Alan Arkin month
it really is Jacob Kelton and chat says
talk about Zack Snyder's Rebel Moon cab
do we know anything about it other than
he's making it did they drop a trailer
or something they haven't dropped the
trailer yet I think they dropped a sort
of behind the scenes little like two
minute featurette out of the to dumb
Netflix conference in Brazil about a
month ago or so but yeah they haven't
shown and I think a couple Stills have
leaked as well but there's not been a
trailer yet I'm in I [__] like Zach
um Jersey Boy but uh I mean this is him
doing his Star Wars essentially right
yeah basically
I'm in but there's no trailer
um I thought I thought based on them
saying is like oh my God
maybe there's a trailer I missed we
didn't talk about the trailer from
um Craven did we
yeah
not on the air
did we I think you and I talked about it
and I was like I was overly excited by
it you know like oh my God
you'll never learn you're like why do
you do this and I was like I think it
looks good
yeah one of the only times Mark kind of
made me feel stupid whereas like come on
now yeah he goes now we gotta have
[__] he gets bit by a lion and
becomes like a [__] Hunter manible
this is good Manimal meets Beast Master
I tell you that trailer was better than
it had any right to be when they
announced a craven movie I was like
why are they doing this but I saw that
trailer I was like [__] hey it's John
Wick he's just killing [__] right my
favorite part though has been like the
the tick tock thirst trap reaction to
the poster
like Tick Tock is losing its [__]
mind over you know Aaron whatever his
name is Taylor Johnson just leaning back
no shirt on big thighs just like oh hey
Craven you can hunt me you can you can
isn't he um [__] uh what was that
movie called
you know where he was the teen vigilante
get gas yes I mean I know he's
Quicksilver
um but he's Kick-Ass yeah he's kickass
guys got [__] jacked
yeah he was also in uh bullet train
which I quite liked him in
um
yeah he plays an assassin along with uh
apparently Brothers with Brian Terry
Henry who are both hilarious
um and he was in the that first Godzilla
reboot movie The Post Matthew Broderick
won
where he just got to like look around
and maybe see Godzilla yeah with wasn't
Elizabeth
no who's his wife yeah
he's a good actor in this kid [__] I
gotta tell you man that [__] like I
had I had zero expectations for Craven
and I saw that trailer I'm like
I'm interested you have my attention
it's morbin time
no I don't know it's not bad about
Morgan
but yeah I I get I'm I am an eternal
optimist I'm like this is gonna be great
that's all the news we got that's all
the news we got
man qma
uh what do you got what do you got there
bamf man give us some questions
three uh first question Ian Cruz
uh if you could direct a music video
what band and what song
would you want to do what would the
video Pitch be
uh before we do that hey we should point
out that we are doing fat man beyond
live one week from tonight that's right
we are yeah if you're in California kids
uh you want to come see me and Mark and
Banff Man live in person at the scum and
villainy cantina
here's your chance come to the dance man
uh fat man beyond live
one week from tonight which would be
what July 10th
yeah I attend yeah the last time in LA
for a long time I think it's definitely
the last La show before we do the sold
out [__] uh show in New Jersey fat
man beyond August 25th is sold out kid
so and then whatever may or may not
happen in San Diego
oh that's right oh you're yeah that's
right we are doing it in San Diego
spoilers we are we'll be doing fat man
Beyond in San Diego we I think after the
holiday July 5th tickets go on sale for
um uh we're doing movies again at the
Tin Roof Inn like we did
last year and we're doing Thursday night
is Jay and Silent Bob get old Friday
night is fatten and Beyond with me and
Mark on Saturday night is uh Hollywood
Babylon with me and Ralph Garmin so
that's right there will be one more in
California
and then August 25th the sold out show
in New Jersey but in Los Angeles Man
tickets available right now how do they
get them bamf man uh I posted the link
in the chat and then I'll put it up over
my face because the other one's not
working
right there over my face
so [__] do me here buy those tickets
right now we'll wait we ain't saying
[__] until you buy some tickets
you buy them tickets
getting separated
um get your tickets right now kids
come see me and Mark do this live in
person it's always a good time to come
and villainy cantina J.C Penney's
[__] hell of a bar man where
everyone's accepted good times are have
by all
nobody ever gets in barfized it ain't
like Roadhouse at all there's no blood
on the floor every night yeah I know
that [__] you don't have a Roadhouse guy
right a bouncer Roadhouse guy I do not
a tiny dancer in the corner not even a
stoner anymore and sometimes language
we don't have a Roadhouse guy do you
door guys
do you have a Super Mario guy like do
you mean a plumber
do you have a bouncer villain we do
because we're on Hollywood Boulevard so
we're trying to keep some of the
riffraff outside but uh he is a uh
Tolkien scholar so like when he's not
doing our door he's researching J.R.R
Tolkien and Lord of the Rings so do you
have any thoughts on Narnia is he like
Narnia
you know I don't ask I'm not Narnia is
not really on my right like I don't like
to get close to the help man because I
need him to take a bullet if somebody if
the Riff Raff comes in Hollywood
Boulevard does uh does the does the
north the Tolkien scholar when looking
at IDs and he bounces people from
entering say
you shall not pass oh my God and if he
doesn't he should he should dress like
[__] Gandalf
or no or the balrog oh my God that'd be
nice smoking flame and that's coming
from a guy who never saw all them Rings
movies I know you got the name right
I can pass man
um okay so uh tickets right now get them
come see me and Mark at [__] scum and
villainy Canton you can drink [__]
blue milk for Christ's sakes
can't they have the blue
yes they can can I reveal something that
we're gonna do but I'm sure a bunch of
other bars will steal because I'm saying
it on the show but it'll help oh yeah
it'll sell one [__] ticket go I have
uh it won't be ready for this show but
it we we are going to do I took a uh
barbasol shaving
can create like a can of shaving cream
and I hollowed it out and you take the
shaving cream off and it has all the
little vials of like Dino embryos but
they're little shooters
so you can order the Jurassic Park drink
you get a shaving cream can you pop it
open and it has the like spring action
and they pop up and then their little
shot shooters that's [__] clever man
you call it the Wayne Knight or what
yeah yeah we've referenced we actually
call it the uh the Newman
[__] good man JC's clever he's
putting it you know [__]
they should let you make a movie
whichever one you want yeah
bigger than me
okay that kind of attention to detail
deserves [__]
be rewarded with a 100 to 200 million
dollar Hollywood game
[Music]
it's the other thing we didn't talk
about with Indiana Jones and the dial of
Destiny 300 million dollars
damn
flash 200 and change like these movies
are too expensive man
somebody better tell folks that like you
better bring these budgets down
bring that budget down son lay that
budget down I mean like
yeah like I I I just struggle with
how one spends 300 million dollars on a
movie
by taking a guy's face and making it
young they could have just been this
somebody could have stood behind
Harrison
I hate snakes jock I hate them but like
you know they're they're people in their
basements you know who could deep fake a
Harrison Ford for free
yeah you know like that's just it's
always
like I guess I get it but the same token
like
really
uh Mission Impossible
another budget High budget movie yeah
yeah but you see that all the uh pull
the figure for that but they were also
shooting during covet they got shut down
multiple times yeah
their budget is also [__] like
through the roof
um what what is it is it Mission
possible seven now seven yeah
part one yes
290 million dollars
I mean you know
I mean like there's there's I oh the one
thing I will say in defense of of
whatever that is is that they actually
travel the world and make these movies
there is nothing that takes place in
Indiana Jones that does not feel like it
could have been on a set agreed Brett
Cohen and Chacos that's a budget for two
movies I don't think that's accurate the
story I read said that the 295 million
is dead reckoning part one
like it's not the two movies
it's not like that's part one and part
two they shot him at the same time I
don't think that's the case here
I could be wrong
but I I remember reading an article that
was just like that's just part one
it's not like you know when they shot
[__] Infinity war and [__] end
game together and then you know right
this is that's one movie
um it looks it though I mean
it had a lot to do but also but it
sounds like it's not all on screen
because it had a lot to do with covet as
well
yeah they got [__] killed man
remember well because he was you know
going out of his way to make sure that
they could make that movie didn't they
like rent a cruise ship to house the the
crew so that they didn't have to be in
whatever City they were shooting in
yeah
yeah anyway so music video what uh
what's the band what song music video
and what's the what's the concept
um I've made some music videos
um let me see uh
uh for Soul Asylum
or
um are they going to be on a cruise with
us oops that's right ooh [__] hell of
a Segway kids do you want to spend some
time on the high seas or the in my case
not so high anymore see
uh you're not even supposed to see here
today that was Brian Lynch's pitch uh
it's uh the Jay and Silent Bob's Cruise
the skew coming at you in February man
uh February I think it's 20
fifth to the 27th I don't know but it's
Feb of February 2024. we are at 75 sold
still have many months to sell more so
it's July August September October
November December January February seven
months to sell the other 25 3
000 usq fans alone on a boat
that sounds like smoking recipe for
disaster but it's Gonna Be Heaven for me
uh we got so much programming Mark
Bernardin is going to be there we're
going to be doing fat man beyond on a
boat we're on a boat [__] and
Beyond but like Mark said Soul Asylum is
going to be joining us on the cruise
um Dave Turner and Co and uh Jason Lee
just signed up Ethan suplee Brian
o'holleran Jeff Anderson me and Jason
Muse doing Jay and Silent Bob good old
Ralph Garmin and me doing Hollywood
Babylon
um
uh Trevor Fuhrman Elias
and them clerks pictures Jennifer
[__] schwalbach
played Emma in those pictures and [__]
um yeah man if you've ever wanted to go
to the Bahamas with me here's your
chance like it's a I think it's Jay and
Silent Bob's cruisesque.com a very long
[__] or just go to my Instagram it's
in my
my uh Link in my
bio.com but join us on the cruise man
come cruise with us haven't you always
wanted to cruise with me and Mark right
on Hollywood Boulevard you
know cruising
um okay
um let's see what video would I want to
do
all right I would love to do a video for
the Talking Heads which would mean they
would have to get back together oh nice
and it would be for a new song
uh or
it would be for two songs one would be a
new track
and the other would be for
because they've had some amazing videos
um
I mean they've always they were RISD
kids from Rhode Island School of Design
so like the look of their videos is
always hey you know what I'm not good
enough to make a Talking Heads video
but I would want to be I just want to
see the Talking Heads play together
again it's fair that's really all it
comes down to
um I'm I'm not honestly I'm not really a
video type of guy because that requires
a Visionary somebody who could tell a
visually interesting story in like two
to four minutes and I ca they give me 90
minutes I can't tell a visual
interesting story
so um
I you know maybe Tenacious D even they
make good looking videos wow
um
hmm
you know oh all right here you go they
never made a music video for Cats in the
Cradle
Harry Chapin garbage sorry taping on him
though there's a carpenter on his name I
would I would do that [__]
but very literal just there's a cat in a
[__] crazy
you see me my friend people like I think
he literally thinks this song about a
cat in a cradle I was like what do you
mean it's not shit's adorable yeah I'm
just feeding with a silver spoon just
look at this cat just eating all this
[__] pudding I would literally show
you all the things he says Little Boy
Blue Man in the Moon right like I don't
think he understands what that song
means it's a song about a father who
didn't spend enough time with his
children no it isn't it's about little
boy blue feeding a cat with a silver
spoon on the moon you're being literal
it's about a cat in a cradle what's more
adorable than that nothing there aren't
nearly enough cats in music video I was
a big fan of lol cats back in the day
I can has video
oh
my friend
my friend uh I think I want to do
um parliaments
make my funk the P Funk because I wants
to get funked up
uh animated in the style of the Soul
Train opening credits
I remember those openings that [__]
train so
wow good call man yeah I should have
went with animated [__]
listen man I'm here now for the [__]
Cat in the Cradle being fed by little
boy blue holding a silver spoon
as the slickness M says in Chat Cat
videos made YouTube
absolutely right so we're gonna remake
the music video we're gonna bring back
MTV with cat videos and [__]
my my fault with people
wasted good time as children teenagers
Even in our 20s watching music videos
and MTV and that doesn't even happen
anymore no no I don't even I do you have
to go to YouTube to find a video if you
want but even then like I don't even
know who's making them anymore
so the last one I saw was Janelle Monae
launching her like here's my titties
tour
um which here for I'm here for her you
know sort of sexual Freedom
um but yeah that's the last music video
I saw in three or four years
here's our answer so we did it
yeah I would do a Taylor Swift video
because
money people see it
there's I wasn't even thinking I was
thinking of [__] I don't know what
else I like cats is what it comes down
now but you're right man I should have
picked an artist that people demand to
see videos
[Music]
uh all right hyper hex asks uh if you
could cross over Indiana Jones with any
comic book character who would it be and
what would be the item
hmm
I'll I'll go because I read the question
like an hour ago so it's been in the
back of my brain it literally shot
people must have thought that we froze
or something because like it was dead
silence as we all sat there thinking you
go first let's see if it uh I think
Indiana Jones could have a wonderful
adventure with gray ghost from Batman
hmm
nice
and they're searching for
it doesn't matter it's not about that
it's about their camaraderie
I like it I like it you had an hour to
think you couldn't come up with a phone
um I I'm thinking uh Indiana Jones
crosses over with green arrow
and they're looking for the Lost bow of
Robin Hood
thank you just came up with that on the
spot that's nice thank you very much
over to you Captain well done
um I want to cross him over with
um Vandal Savage
remember Vandal Savage from the DC yeah
he's the oldest man in DC history The
Immortal Cro-Magnon Warrior who has
survived throughout the ages
um
you know I I think that a dude who loves
the deep deep best and a guy who's lived
the deep deep past would have some
interesting conversations
and I think the item they want to find
is [__] Atlantis
just do it just go find a dead City
[__] hey I like that or I would cross
Indiana Jones over with Richie Rich and
they could go find the box office that
they didn't find this weekend
[Music]
did I do that
I'm gonna stick with my original answer
no that was a good one though thank
you
um all right Jace JC bring us back how
about this it's on the fact that I saw
two movies where uh Nazis got the [__]
kicked at him this weekend Indiana Jones
crosses Over The Blues Brothers and they
fight Illinois Nazis
and [__] Jake Jake Blues goes I hate
Illinois Nazis and then Andy Jones goes
I hate snakes jock I hate them but it's
a prequel
because
Abner Ravenwood taught at University of
Chicago which is where Blues Brothers
takes places in Chicago oh my God hey is
that true did he really teach at Chicago
yeah
how do you know so much about Abner
Ravenwood I think this it's dialogue I
think uh that one of the CIA guys says
in Raiders
I mean
Ernie's not wrong it wouldn't have been
cool to see [__] young old Indiana
Jones teaming up with Abner Ravenwood
one of my favorite La things ever was
when I first
um visited La for a stretch and I was
doing an internship on the Paramount lot
um I remember driving down Vine
and passing by the Ravenwood Apartments
on my way to the Paramount lot I was
like do you think that's where they came
up with the name Abner Ravenwood from
Marion Ravenwood and yeah like Lawrence
gazden uh admitted like yeah that was
the Ravenwood Apartments I saw that name
yeah it's well there's if you take
Beverly Glenn over the hill
there's a there's a street sign that's
Ravenwood court and so it's yeah it's
all right there
in the valley there's an Arcola Avenue
and I always thought that was where they
got Chachi Arcola from
days
is named after UCLA
are you [__] me is that true yeah
that would make a lot of [__] sense
what about uh Indiana Jones and Doc
Savage the man of bronze ooh see that'd
be dope or Indiana Jones and the Venture
Brothers
yes
yes please
Indiana Jones and uh and just go
straight back to the service for Johnny
Quest
Mike hey you've also got a little brown
kid sidekick this is great
why don't we take a page out of JC's
book and it's Indiana Jones crosses over
with uh [__] Taylor Swift so that it
makes a lot of money
that's why every teen girl and older
gentleman comes to see this [__]
movie
um
every kid here's the one we [__]
missed Deanna Jones wait for it and Han
Solo
wow it's like looking at myself in the
mirror and they're looking for Luke
Skywalker's lost lightsaber that [__]
fell out of his hand
cut his hand off the one that was
originally in JJ's movie and then they
were like let's not do that yeah that's
crazy
so yeah
love it great question
all right what's the last one all right
last one D Payne wants to know uh if you
could direct any biography
who or what would you choose
Stan Lee
said
enough said
uh I would do a Stanley biopic I've been
offered to do a Stanley biopic to be
honest with you I probably wouldn't do
it because I'm too I don't know I might
be too close on that subject matter
um
George Carlin
Alan Rickman three dead Legends who I
actually met
so I feel like I could I could do them
Justice
hmm
I think I would do
um
Jimi Hendrix
oh
there's never been a good one
um
because I think the issue is always the
music the music rights are tied up in a
very contentious sort of estate battle
there's like nine different members of
the Hendricks family all of whom have
different opinion opinions on whatever
so
there was a there was a movie starring
Andre 3000 as Jimi Hendrix
um which was interesting but all the
music was the covers that he did
um so none of the original stuff but if
you could crack that
I think that story is awesome
um
I feel like
there's probably a great Chuck Jones
story
to be told
um I don't know an overwhelming amount
about his life but the the work the
conditions under which they did the work
the ability to mix animation live action
to tell that story I think would be kind
of phenomenal
I would do I would do this guy right
here yeah Jason mew's bio I know a lot
about this book you can probably get the
rights
yeah I bet you I bet you I know a guy I
can get the rights but I know a lot
about Jason and he's got a pretty
[__] interesting story I wrote years
ago like the whole reason Jane sound Bob
get old exists as a podcast is because
it came off of
um a kind of series of essays that I
wrote called me and my shadow which is
about his struggles with with drug
addiction back in the day
um but yeah that'd be I and for years
people have been like you should turn
that into a movie
um and for years I've been like no God
no
but now that should happen like he just
said his 13-year sober anniversary
um the other day yesterday so
congratulations to Jason mussman sober
Queen's over 13 years now the father of
two
but inspiring story there's a kid who
didn't [__] that's a great American
story right there guy who got as far as
he's got in life by being a true
American original
and you know I had demons to fight and
[__] fought him and [__]
and his beloved I mean he [__] you
gotta you've seen how beloved Jason Muse
is it's [__] nuts people love this
kid I hitched my wagon to a store a long
[__] time ago because I was like
people like this guy they don't like me
but they like him so I'm gonna stand
next to him for the rest of my life both
professionally and personally
Jay never lost going through all that he
never lost like that sense of being a
kid either
like he still has that like Wonder and
enthusiasm that like a nine-year-old
little kid has
100 one of the most Charming aspects
about him that's why children [__]
love him not just his kids of course his
kids love him but like kids in general
when they meet him just [__] flock to
him he's like the Pied Piper because he
he's like them he's just [__] like
into life and into like this is one of
the things I've always loved about him
this [__] has never read about a
bad comic book he's never seen a bad
movie
he's never seen a bad TV show he likes
everything we'd give him the shittiest
Comics back in the day
like we get rid of because we didn't
want our collection
and he'd be like I loved it I was like
what'd you like about it he's like oh I
was in color like there's always
something positive he's got to say he's
not judgmental at all I wish I could be
that guy in life
yeah he's a good guy
um what about you Banff Man Who Would
You biopic I would do Bill Murray
Bill Murray grew up down the street from
my
my dad's family he's older than my dad
but um but they all went to Catholic
High School together and uh I just think
he's got like a really interesting
origin and then it just goes off the
rails crazy from there
I think you missed your opportunity you
should have done Taylor Swift again
let's see the biopic that makes money
and [__]
Blank Space the Taylor Swift story
budget
uh well [__] there it is man we
talked about we reviewed some [__] we
did some news and [__] then we answered
some questions and [__] so shit's done
you come see us
kids you wanna come see me and Mark in
person
me and Uncle Mark
Uncle stiffy let's go
uh come watch us do this [__] [__]
live man I mean this is lives but I mean
in person and [__] yeah you can touch it
in a bad seat at the [__] scum and
villain in Cantina you can roll up a
tissue hurl it at us and shatter our jaw
that's how close you are
and that's how old we are the old glass
jaw
um somebody Jim Tomlin just said you
forgot about Super Chat Mark's like shut
the [__] up we made it almost all the
way out
son of a [__]
um yeah man come see us tickets
available right now at that link that's
on the screen uh Batman uh oh it's that
Eventbrite just go to Eventbrite and
[__] enter fat man beyond you'll find
it cease mod or any number of places
don't forget to go see
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny
make up your own mind
um seek out
by any means necessary at all costs to
your physical person late night with the
devil leave this mountain flick [__]
telling me man that [__] is low I'm
gonna say it again
I'll probably get misquoted somewhere
online and they'll say that I said
Christian Bale
did a thing
this [__] thing is like Rosemary's
Baby meets Network
and I believe the network that they
they're on a network called UBC in the
um Dave's movie I think that was the
name of the network and Network
I gotta remember
I don't remember either
Uh Kevin it's nine o'clock Do You Know
Where Your Children Are
do you remember do you remember that
yeah in the 70s it's 10 p.m You Know
Where Your Children Are I don't know
five years to do that back East yeah
because apparently parents in the 70s
were so awful they did not know where
their kids were
and so awful that TV had to TV to remind
them it's 10 o'clock remember
yeah where's that product of all that
[__]
um that was at a time where like you
know kids would go out now it's like if
you did it's 10 o'clock do you know
where your kid is like yeah he's [__]
twitching in the Next Room
he never leaves the [__] house he's
jerking off to tick tock where else is
he supposed to be
he's watching Euphoria which scares me
I don't understand it there it is kids
uh there's your
fat man beyond
for this week don't forget
we're doing it
Nicholas hannel said by the way Stephen
King has been touting late night with
the devil all over his Twitter feed
oh
[Music]
Stephen King and Stephen King like The
Flash and so did I and look what that
did
hopefully better results for Dave
dismalchen and uh and uh late night with
the devil or the same results if late
night with the devil opens the 50
million dollars yeah it's a win oh my
God just pull it out of the theaters
guys we're done I'll take that kind of
failure
um there it is kids [__] there's your
fat man beyond for this week uh next
week we're doing it live from the scum
and villainy cantina come
come come hard go get your ticket right
now join us get drunk and look at us in
person and be like hey hey Uncle Mark I
got a question fix my movie
hey I liked Indiana Jones Uncle Mark
you've never been accosted by a drunk
who differs with from your opinion have
you it hasn't happened yet but uh I now
I I somehow think it's going to happen
here's your chance you conjured it into
the world you could come in and [__]
tell Mark he's wrong to his [__] face
like four drinks in be like hey
hey
you don't like nothing
what who hurt you when you were a child
to catch on you watch I can't wait for
the t-shirts
uh friends uh we don't have a show
without old Banff man Banff man bringing
you even though we're not at his bar
we're at his virtual bar right here yeah
I'm sure that we beam into your homes
so you could [__] catch up on the
latest news
but we got no show without the guy
that's diagonal from me in this with
square board I appreciate the desire to
like not
it's like I've given up I've given up
trying to [__] point oh wait
there
God damn it
there you you I know you I know you
there he is kids
Mr Mark Bernard look at him look at him
look at him he knew to stay out of the
light
touch my head Indiana Jones touch it
Mark's head is the [__] goal
I'm the fertility God he's gonna put a
sandbag down and take Mark's head away
that picture makes me want to watch that
movie again it's worth it you should
hold up
uh give it up for marvelous Uncle Mark
Bernard and ladies and gentlemen thank
you uh that is your fat man beyond for
this week uh don't forget get tickets
see us live one week from today we could
be doing this in the same [__] room
it'd be amazing and [__]
uh that's Batman and beyond for this
week I'm Kevin Smith I'm Mark Bernard
tune in next week kids live from this
coming villainy Cantina same that time
same fat Channel smodcast.com or
youtube.com Kevin Smith Abner Ravenwood
kiss
[Music]
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
[Music]